I'm so busy.
I didn't start exactly at 5.
But Doki, where's Doki?
Every time I don't start exactly at 5.
Where's Doki?
Is she napping?
Where is she?
Oh my god, she's late.
I'm so sorry guys that I started 40 seconds after 5.
Oh my god, what a sin.
How could she?
How could Doki do this to us?
Starting 40 seconds after 5.
She fucking hates us.
She hates us, dragoons.
Shake my head.
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Betrayed.
How could she?
Oh my god.
Anyway guys, I'm sorry I didn't start at exactly at 5.
I actually had like my sense of time got in the way because like I was working on like 3 different projects simultaneously.
In the last like hours.
It's just like...
I was just like...
And I was like, oh f... and I was like, okay, it's 4.50.
Surely I can work an additional 9 more minutes before I start stream.
I was like...
And I was like, oh sh...
I didn't even pull up any of my applications.
I didn't boot up the game or anything in the last minute.
Alright, it's 4.59.
I can boot up everything in one minute.
Let's go.
Oh my god, there's so many things.
And I have to pack it.
Oh my gosh, yesterday, I've been so busy yesterday.
Okay, so we have 60...
Recently, I don't know when I tweeted this, but recently, we received 60 giant packages of like, of debut Doki Bird merch.
So, 60 boxes!
There's like barely space in my tiny apartment right now.
So like, the lobby people called us and was like, Hey!
We received a lot of packages.
And I was just like, Huh?
And I was like, oh sh...
And it came in with like 30.
So like, 30 first.
And then...
And then like, And then more came...
30 more came.
And I was just like...
I was just like, oh my god.
There's 60... I did not...
Okay, look.
We were told... I ordered...
We were told it was 60 boxes.
And...
I was told it was 60 boxes, but I couldn't comprehend...
how many 60 was.
I couldn't...
I couldn't comprehend...
how many 60 boxes actually was.
Because I was like, oh that's not that much, right?
Because I lost my sense of like, how many people is alive.
So...
So I was like...
Oh, 60 is not...
that bad.
And then...
Boxes kept coming into my apartment.
More and more...
and more.
And I was just like...
So I don't have a hallway anymore.
And like, it's so bad...
that like...
You know where the...
When you walk in the pathway where the boxes are, there's like barely light.
There is...
There is barely any light.
When you start walking through the hallway.
Because the boxes just tower above you.
And uh...
So...
I've been like slowly packaging them myself.
Yesterday.
So I like packaged like two.
Yes, okay.
I packaged two because I have to organize the inventory and stuff like that.
Um...
You guys must be wondering, why are you packaging them yourself?
Good question!
Mom, why am I packaging them?
So...
Anyway, I'm slowly sorting...
sorting it out.
With myself at the moment.
Anyway, I hope to like...
I hope we can start shipping them... shipping them out uh... next week.
Well, it's gonna be slowly.
I'm so sorry if it's gonna be like...
If there is a delay in the end, I am so sorry.
I'll...
I'll try to be more transparent about it if there is gonna be a delay going forward.
But I'm trying my best to like...
start uh...
to like uh... package them and sending them out.
The bundles might take a bit longer uh... to do.
Um... because I don't think I ordered enough packaging materials for...
for the bundle.
So I've like... I recently ordered more envelopes and stuff like that.
Uh...
for the...
for all the merch.
And...
uh... and...
um... but I can start shipping the smaller stuff.
Like the people who order the smaller things.
Because I have enough of that.
Of that.
But like for the bundles...
and stuff.
There might... there might be a little delay for the bundles.
Just a little bit.
I hope.
But if it does end up being a longer delay...
I'll try to be transparent with you guys.
I'll give you guys updates about it.
So time to re... I thought I had a warehouse!
I like gave... okay.
Like that's why I was like... I'm gonna start like being more on top of things.
Because I was so busy.
So I delegated some of the stuff.
Uh...
to my parents.
Because they said they wanted to work on that for me.
And then...
so I thought I had a warehouse.
Until I got 60 packages sent to my apartment.
And I was like...
Where's the distributor?
I was like...
I was like... I thought this was gonna be sent to the distributor.
And then...
And then I was like...
So...
So I was like...
I guess I'm the warehouse now.
I don't know what's going on.
That's why... I don't know what's going on at the moment.
But I don't wanna be like late with orders.
Um...
So yeah.
My apartment's the distributor.
My apartment's the warehouse for now.
So like I'm trying to be like on top of like... There's a lot of things going on.
So like I'm trying to be like super on top... Not on top.
Like okay.
I can't say I'm on top of everything when my apartment is literally the warehouse right now.
But... It's been pretty rough because like... I'm doing like hundreds of jobs at once every day.
And I'm hoping that next week when I have my actual break break that like everything is...
Everything is like I guess like settled.
Or like finally organized.
Um...
And like I'm actually looking... I'm currently also... Okay.
I'm like doing so many things.
I'm actually currently looking for a place for myself.
Like to live on my own.
Technically like I used to live on my own.
And then like... And then my parents started living with me.
I pay for the rent and everything by the way.
So it's not like you know I'm living like at my parents place.
My parents are living with me.
Um... But like I'm to like...
Starting yesterday I've been like actually looking for a place for myself.
To be more like um...
Independent.
And then I guess like use my other... This apartment as a warehouse I guess.
Because...
.
And like I will have to pay like two rents.
But that's okay because I'm thankful for you Dragoons for like supporting me.
So that I can afford to pay technically like if I when I do get my new place.
I'll be paying for two rents.
I'm not buying a place because like in...
Despite the amount of support you guys have given me.
Like the housing...
The house...
The real estate...
The real estate market in Canada is fucking terrible.
So...
So despite... Yeah in this economy.
Like you guys support me so much.
But like...
In this economy and the housing market like I'm not gonna be buying a place anytime soon.
Next...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... Power you don't get help living on your own goes well.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fiction.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for playing the game that the most amount hours played in my entire library.
Weighing over 2000.
Okay to be fair that's never...
That's not as much as my dad.
He's been playing this game for like two...
For like two to three years non-stop every day.
So like since it got launched.
Sometimes he goes back to it.
Like ever so often.
So like the intro of Fallout 4 is like fucking ingrained in my head.
Because I've seen him replay the intro.
He created numerous characters.
Um...
Multiple times.
I feel like every time I see him play Fallout 4 it's a new character.
So like I fucking know the intro by heart.
Like...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Media thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Would say this to the Doki House but yeah the housing market.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
But yeah I am really...
I... Oh my gosh.
I haven't like looked for my own place for so long.
I think for like...
I think like for a very long time since I guess like since you know...
Since like... Oh my gosh.
I don't remember.
I have like usually like um...
I don't have to look for myself.
Uh... But like I don't even know if... I hope like... I hope like my future landlords if I see a place and I don't have to compete with like 50 other people.
Like I'm pretty sure I'm gonna have to compete with 50 plus other people.
And then like I... I feel like if they find out I have a dog they'll be like no.
The hardest part is finding a pet friendly... um...
apartment to rent as well.
And that's like the hardest part because usually landlords would be like no pet the bet... like the better... the bet...
the bet... the better you are as in like you know pets quiet.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Good credit.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
No noise complaints.
Oh fuck.
I need to find a place that has like... that has good...
That has thick walls.
I... I know that like some places they'll be like um... if you...
they'll have like 50 plus uh... people... applicants.
They'll have 50 plus applicants.
And then... and then they'll choose the one with zero... no pets.
Uh...
Not uni... I guess like sometimes they prefer university students because they are like university students that study and like know they won't party or anything.
Because like that was me.
I remember like as a university student I... I was like the go to class... like the go to applicant.
I was basically the dream applicant.
The dream tenant for so many landlords.
Like every time I applied for like a place because at that time I didn't have like Doki Amber Doge.
So like they'll be like oh my god she has no pets.
She's by herself.
She's alone.
Uh... Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha She obviously only studies like look at her.
She doesn't party.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha And she's just... she's...
She seems like a... like a good person.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha So every time... I remember in the past I would apply for a place.
I would be like... I instantly get it.
Like I don't think I've ever been rejected for a place.
Just because in university I was like a university student.
But like I had like all the good traits of a university student.
Like and like I was able to afford um...
like a decent place.
I guess like quote on quote decent place.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha For like a single person.
So like... so then they'll like oh...
And by the... back then I didn't stream as well.
So there was zero noise complaints.
I... I also did not stream.
So I had zero noise complaints.
So they're like jeez perfect.
I remember one time I like tried to I actually like I was actually looking at several places.
And had several landlords trying to compete for me as a tenant.
It's that... it's that fucking crazy.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha Like what was like um... was like a basement... like what was it called?
Like a basement suite?
So like there was a family that was living... you know the family was renting out their... their basement suite.
And the other one was an apartment.
And um...
And then like obviously I'm sorry to the family...
to the family in the...
I'm sorry to the family in the basement suite.
But I rejected the basement suite because like obvi... like there was a... they had a little baby.
So... Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha They...
They had... they had a...
They had a baby.
And I was like Oh no.
Will I be considered like a free babysitter for them in the future?
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha They were in like the suburbia.
They were in suburbia too.
So I was just like oh no.
I have to walk to the bus stop.
Instead of like going...
Like I have to walk several blocks to get to the bus stop.
To like get to my university.
But like you know the other one the bus stop was like you know it was at an apartment at a decent place.
So it was like I just have to walk like maybe like three minutes to the bus stop to get to my university.
So I was like No I'm sorry.
But then like the app... the landlord for the basement suite.
They like sent me like several emails to convince me... Ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha They sent me like several emails to like...
convince me to choose them as like their like to choose them to rent.
They're like we think you're the perfect tenant.
Like how's the application going?
Cause like they're like oh we need... like it's just like it's the rules.
You need to fill out this application and stuff like that.
And they sent me like two emails two to three emails being like Oh what do you think?
Like we really think you're the perfect tenant for us.
Like we really want you to rent our place.
Like oh how's the application going on?
I felt so sad.
Cause I was like oh I'm sorry.
I found another place that like suits me better.
Even the apartment tenant also was like Oh we think you're the perfect tenant.
Like I literally just did like one I just went to one um I went to like one like you know where you have to like look around the apartment and then just like talk like just talk to them and just be like...
what your thoughts are and stuff.
And after that they'll be like after that they'll be like oh I think you're perfect.
Like I think we will I think like the apartment guy was like right after the interview and like looking around the apartment they were like oh yeah we think we want you to be the tenant.
Like the open house.
Yeah yeah yeah.
The open house.
Cause like they were like right after the open house they were like oh yeah yeah we want you to be our tenant.
Like yeah we're not we're not gonna look at the other other applicants anymore.
And I was like oh okay yeah I think this is a good place.
Make them...
It's gonna make them fight.
I think it's also cause like I've... you know how... okay so um I'm like the ideal tenant because like the reason why I'm the ideal tenant is because like I write my checks in advance.
So basically like I just give them like 6 months of checks in advance and be like so I don't have to keep up with it.
You know?
So I don't I don't So I just be like okay like you don't have to chase me for rent.
I was just like I pays on time.
Doesn't party.
Like just didn't stream at that time.
So I didn't No noise complaints.
And then I'll just be like, okay, here's like, here's some checks in advance.
So like, you know, I hope I have the money by then, but like, I think I have the money by then when you deposit these checks every month, but you don't have to pay.
You don't have to chase me in advance.
Okay, anyway, but yeah, so, so I hope that's the same because it's different now.
It's different now.
I have a dog.
And so I have a dog.
I stream.
And so there's going to be noise complaints maybe.
And it's like, I'm just like, oh man.
And it's so people, people don't fucking buy houses here.
We all fucking rent because the housing market is fucking terrible in Canada.
I don't know how it can get worse, but it did.
I remember five years ago, I was like, how can this get worse?
And then it still gets worse.
Like it's still, buying houses can still go up.
Did we not learn anything from the first financial crisis?
Like, did we not learn anything from the first housing crash?
I don't know, but it's back up again.
Yeah.
And anyway, anyway.
I hope I'm still.
The ideal tenant.
Cause like, I've been like looking around for places to like, to see like where I could rent.
It's so hard.
It's so difficult because like, I have like so many other factors now that I'm like a streamer, like a content creator and I have a fucking pet.
So there's so many factors to look into now when it comes to like, uh, when it comes to finding a place, just finding a pet friendly place is so difficult.
It's so fucking.
Difficult.
Anyway.
Anyway, everybody, sorry for the 23 minute tangent.
Guys, but let's play the game.
Yeah.
Where's fallout?
Okay.
There's fallout four.
It's time.
I'm super excited to try out fallout four.
I never played fallout four.
Uh, my, I never.
Whoa.
Sorry.
The game was like, went crazy.
On my, it's definitely not 244 Hertz because the game started like adjusting my Hertz and stuff and was like, this is not it.
Well, I tab, if I tab, I would've fucked with my, okay.
It didn't, I was going to say what it was like.
It like the monitor like flickered and stuff.
Oh, you saw that flicker.
Yeah.
Oh, please don't.
Oh my gosh.
Where's my cursor?
Where's the cursor?
Where is it?
Wait.
Okay.
I see my cursor on the other monitor.
Ooh.
Okay.
Give me a sec guys.
I got to figure out where my, my cursor went.
Oh, Bethesda.
Bethesda.
All right guys, let me restart the game.
I don't know where my cursor went.
I was like, where did it go?
It just works.
Oh yeah.
Here we go.
All right.
Play.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Special.
Parts.
Six.
What makes you special?
What makes me special?
Whoa.
That's a nuclear bomb.
Total atomic
uneducational materials for you to better understand the seven defining attributes.
I don't have a controller plugged in.
What do you mean?
Agility.
A nuclear blast and the subsequent fallout will have many adverse effects on life as we know it.
Intensive prolonged radiation exposure may transform.
Oh my God.
Good.
Into decrepit rotting beings that have lost their ability to reason.
I bet someone would still want to bang that though.
Common manners and quick to anger.
Not me.
Of course.
To make the most of
will only take you so far.
Now let's try that again.
Yeah.
Me.
Straps.
Yes.
Me.
Especially after the show.
Oh.
Somebody here really liked the gore.
Whoa.
Who needs agility if I go all attack.
I only need agility if I shoot the head.
Okay.
Okay, we're never doing stealth by the way, guys.
Exactly!
No need to dodge if they're dead!
What?
You have little targets when the...
Regularly study your Vault-Tec provided materials to prepare for survival.
Them?
And to answer the question, do you know what makes you special?
Yeah!
I do!
Because I'm anime.
Alright, there you go.
Where's my cursor?
What the fuck?
I did all that!
Where the fuck's my cursor?
I'm gonna plug in my controller and see if it finds my cursor.
I can't...
Where the fuck's my cursor?
I can't believe it!
I watched all that and my cursor still didn't fucking show up?
I am pressing enter.
Chat, I pressed enter.
Sorry, another flicker.
Guys!
I'm pressing space and enter!
I don't understand!
Oh my god!
It just works!
Okay, guys.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna Google this.
Where is my...
Where is my cursor?
It just fell out the floor.
Okay, disappearing is likely due to...
Okay, it's not!
I don't have it!
Nope, okay.
Turns out... okay.
But it doesn't!
Go into the settings and turn off controller.
I think it falls under... that's how most games are...
My controller's not even plugged in!
What do they mean?
Okay guys, I'm gonna plug in Borderless windows you're so fucking right guys.
Okay, maybe borderless window will work.
Sorry Borderless Window mode.
Okay.
We're gonna window mode.
This is it.
This has to be it Alright, we're not watching agility and again
All right The cursor DLC You
You literally got so much of my money, Todd!
Why are you doing...
Why are you doing this to me?
I unplugged the controller, guys!
I unplugged it, I swear to God!
I unplugged it!
Alright, let's see...
Not plugged it back in.
Maybe if I just had my controller on, it would be fine.
I already had my controller on.
Okay.
Alright, let's watch this again.
Todd!
Please!
Okay.
You literally got so much of my money, Doki.
Why are you doing this to me?
I don't understand, Todd!
Where did it go?
I hid every key possible!
Oh my God!
Darn you, Todd!
Okay.
I know how to do this, guys.
Okay, we're just gonna...
We're just gonna go to our folders, apparently.
Let me figure...
What was it?
I need to go to the fucking...
I need to go edit a folder.
I need to go to my folder again, guys.
Oh my God.
Can I edit the...
Okay, wait.
Is this...
Is this gonna be like Fallout 76?
I'm having the same issue.
Stuff off...
Maybe it will work.
Okay.
Alright.
Turns out it was my USB...
What the fuck?
Does anyone have the...
I found...
Disconnect your mouse.
Press shift plus tab.
Reconnect your mouse?
What?
Okay.
I got disconnect my mouse.
Shift tab.
Reconnect your mouse.
Uh...
Todd!
Please!
Alright.
Hey.
This is the authentic Pathesics.
Like, everything works but my cursor is not showing up.
Like, what?
Why is my cursor not showing up?
Todd!
Okay.
Um...
Try...
My game would...
My work worked for me I think.
Start going...
Exit...
What is this?
What...
Press E.
Okay.
It's not E guys.
Run this game as...
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Running a game on admin is the...
Alright.
Browse local files.
I swear to fucking god.
Alright.
We're running it as admin.
Will it show up?
Will it register that I have a...
That I have a mouse?
Is it gonna show up?
Will it have a cursor?
Will it press A on your USB?
Okay I plugged in my controller!
And it didn't work.
The game...
Was rigged from the start.
It was...
It...
No.
Come on.
Come on Todd!
Todd!
Come on!
Why Todd?
Alright, controller setting.
Settings.
Steam input.
Alright, okay.
Okay, your controller.
No, I don't wanna fucking- Okay, I'm gonna plug in my controller.
Alright, here we go.
This is like... tech support with the dragoons.
Just like the good old days.
Alright, here we go.
Plugged in my controller.
Alright, enable.
Alright.
Okay.
Now we have- Now we're on controller.
Is that it?
Oh my god!
Okay, okay.
We got a controls display.
Okay guys, we gotta figure a way to make it so that we're not on controller.
I refuse to play this game on controller!
Alright.
Okay, how do I- Controller.
Off.
Wait, okay.
Does that mean it worked?
Where's my mouse?
Okay, now... does my mouse show up?
Oh, it doesn't look like my cursor shows up.
Guys!
Maybe it's just the main menu thing.
Guys.
Truly, Todd can't be wrong!
Carpook.
I'm trying to plug back in my controller.
I can't fucking fit in.
The USB slot.
Everything's going wrong.
Oh my god!
Why can't the- Why doesn't it fit in the hole?
Oh, that's what you want to hear.
Oh no!
Now I have nothing!
Okay.
Guys.
Okay guys.
This is starting to be a little bit of a mess.
Guys.
I- I understand that...
Now I can't even- Apparently, now I can't even turn it back on.
Guys, I fucked up!
Why did I turn off the controller?!
I fucked up!
I can't even use the controller anymore!
Oh my god!
I fucked up!
I won't even let me use the controller!
Because I turned it off!
Oh no!
Guys.
Guys, I realized I made a mistake when I turned off the controller.
It's eventually broken.
Wait, maybe it didn't register.
Maybe it just didn't register, guys.
Maybe it didn't- Don't wait!
This is all Todd's plan!
Todd knows what he's doing!
I believe- Oh, I knew it!
I knew I could believe in Todd!
Oh shit.
Okay, no, I don't want- Wait, there's mods?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Do I have to buy these mods?
Oh!
Can I install this?
Download- Oh, everyone's best friends?
Wait!
Does this mean I can have dog meat?
And- Okay, let's get dog meat and stuff.
Oh!
Does this- Oh my god, does this work?
Todd.
Don't- No, don't buy- Don't pay for those mods!
But that's what Todd wants though!
Todd wants me to pay for the mods!
I can't possibly even listen, but this is amazing content.
Thank you, Super Chat Mr. Broken Fod.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god!
Look, if Todd wants me to pay for mods, maybe he's right, you know?
Maybe he's right.
Oh, these are free?
Oh shit.
Okay.
I would pay- Todd, just letting you know.
If you monetize your mods, I would definitely pay for them.
Me and all the Todd believers would 100% pay for it.
Anyway.
I cannot believe I have to play this on- I can't believe I have to play this on controller.
Start a new game.
Yes.
Don't give it to all two of you!
Todd!
Do it, it would be so funny!
Okay.
Maybe- Guys, maybe, like, my mouse cursor will show up.
Guys.
Just as he- Just as intended!
Entirely trust!
Exactly!
TV, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
If he can get away with Starfield, he can get away with paint marks!
Never changes.
He said the thing!
Serving in the army.
Wondered when he'd get to go home to his wife...
and the son he'd never seen.
He got his wish...
when the US ended World War II...
by dropping atomic bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
The world awaited Armageddon.
Instead...
something miraculous happened.
We began to use atomic energy not as a weapon...
but as a nearly limitless source of power.
Oh my god, we did it!
Enjoyed luxuries once thought the realm of science fiction...
Surely no one would use it for bad!
Fusion powered cars...
portable computers...
And then the world...
And then we discovered world peace, right?
Right?
In the 21st century...
People awoke from the American dream.
What the fuck?
Give this kid a knife!
Years of consumption led to shortages of every major resource.
Subtitles?
Look, I forgot to turn subtitles on because I was going through a lot.
It's understandable!
I went through like the five stages of grief just then!
In 30 minutes!
We stand on the brink of total...
And I am afraid...
For myself...
For my wife...
For my wife?
Wait, who's the...
Because of my time in the army...
Who's the narrator?
Is this the lone wanderer?
The sole survivor?
The vault dweller?
Who the fuck is narrating this?
It's the war...
War never changes.
Wow!
It's me!
The chosen one?
Who is it?
Oh, that's me!
I'm never gonna have my cursor.
Oh, it was me!
Is default guy supposed to be like... Todd?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let me see if I can...
Okay guys, unfortunately...
Um...
Unfortunately, I'm gonna have to use this for...
Use the controller for now.
Alright, who do I wanna look like?
Oh my god!
That light looks like...
God, what's his name?
That guy from...
Oh, General Hux from...
From Star Wars.
Do I wanna be Ginger again?
No, I wanna be a guy, cause like...
The girl's a lawyer.
And like, I don't know.
I don't think I can...
I don't think a lawyer can survive...
What?
Sorry.
What am I...
What am I gonna do?
Like...
Fucking...
Argue myself to safety?
Like...
Be a...
Be a Ginger again?
Alright guys, should we be Ginger again?
You're right.
Maybe I'll...
Maybe I can survive.
Wait, I should...
I don't want him to look...
I don't want my husband to look like that.
Like...
Wait...
Let me change him...
Let me change him back.
I'll make him Default Todd.
I'll make him...
I'll make him Default Todd real quick.
Where's Default Todd?
There it is.
Alright, and then...
Um...
I'm just saying, lawyers are not making it in the wasteland.
She's like a lawyer, apparently.
Alright, we're gonna make her Ginger.
We're gonna go like the Fallout 76 way.
Gingers will survive.
We're gonna make sure the Gingers don't die out.
Uh...
Let's see.
How do I do this?
Okay, we...
My eyes are up here.
Wait, I should...
Were you looking at Dragoons?
My eyes are up here.
Um...
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
And then...
Let's...
There you go.
Alright, let me make sure that...
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Let's...
Let me cook!
Okay, Sultry...
Uh...
Okay.
Is there no long hair?
Agent X?
No, what?
What are these names?
Fairy tales?
Femme Fatale?
Does this look like a Femme Fatale?
Look, I need them to look at my eyes.
They're the gateway to my soul.
Can't have them looking anywhere else.
If I...
So I can tell...
I can tell that they're looking at the right areas.
Where's like...
Natural Beauty?
Public Defender?
Where's long hair?
I guess like in the wasteland you don't want long hair because it's a bitch to clean.
Um...
Oh, I look fucking crazy with that.
Uh...
I don't know.
Alright.
I'll go with...
I guess Elegant.
Blonde, brunette, purple.
Let's see.
I don't know.
Maybe I should look crazy so no one will get close to me.
No, no.
Like, oh no, we can't get close to her.
Even though I'm like a lawyer.
It's all about...
It's all about like faking it till you make it, you know?
So like, I should like look fucked up so that you won't get close to me.
Rough night.
Oh shit.
This was literally called Crazy Warning.
Alright.
I guess the pigtails.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll go with that.
Okay, and then color.
Color.
Deep red.
Ginger!
Wait, is that...
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Guys, I'm beautiful.
Guys, I'm like...
I'm...
Gingers are dying out because like...
Because it's a recessive gene.
So I'm gonna help save the gingers.
I'm gonna...
Let's see.
I think that's good.
And then...
What else can I...
I'm gonna help save.
I'm gonna save the population.
We're gonna repopulate.
Wait, I said that wrong.
Wait, wait a minute.
Alright, let's see.
Damage?
What's the damage?
Oh, no.
Damage.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Is that...
Oh my gosh.
I'm so fucked up.
Okay, we got...
Did she just say looking good?
Try my best, sweetie.
I'm trying my best.
Oh, I can have more freckles?
No, actually, I think I'm okay with that.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Body.
Alright, like I said in 76.
We gotta be...
What?
Shit!
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Guys, as I said in 76, guys, it's all about...
Look.
The more arm muscle you have, the more attractive you are in the wasteland chat.
It's all about the muscle.
They'll hire me.
Because...
They'll be like, oh shit, we need that muscle.
Ginger, diamond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're dying up.
Yes, you guys!
I told you!
In the 76 stream!
Um...
The...
Because, like, having...
Having, like, red hair is, like, a recessive trait.
And apparently, there's been, like...
Apparently, like, it's starting to, like, be phased out.
The longer...
The more years have passed, it's starting to be phased out more and more and more.
So...
So there's, like, eventually, there's gonna be no more gingers.
Which is so fucked up to think about.
It's actually...
It is.
Because it's, like, having red hair is a mutation.
Same with blue eyes.
Uh, having blue eyes is a genetic mutation.
Along with red hair.
And they're both, like, considered recessive genes.
So, like, if, like, obviously, if, like, somebody with, like, different colored eyes or, like, colored hair...
Was, uh, you know, got...
Like, if their wife, husband, um...
Had, like, a different color eyes or hair that's not red hair...
Or, uh, red hair or, like, uh, blue eyes...
Usually, the kids will not have those traits.
So, that's why, like, uh...
That's why, like, gingers are slowly being phased out.
Because it's a recessive gene.
She called me a mutant.
Because to keep the bloodline going for gingers...
You have to, like...
You have to, like, marry another ginger.
Or, like, have kids with another ginger to guarantee red hair.
But, like...
Like, obviously, like...
If you do that too long, then...
Then we have an issue of inbreeding.
So, we don't want that.
We don't want...
Wait, okay, wait.
Uh-huh.
The husband needs...
I just realized.
The husband...
The husband needs to...
Uh...
They're not dying out of recessive genes.
Don't stop existing until there's...
Well, they're, like, slowly getting phased out!
And so, we...
They're rarer and rarer!
It's true!
Okay, wait.
Sound guy.
Uh...
Alright.
Sorry.
I need to...
There...
Okay.
So, we know why he died.
I may be a lawyer, but...
But it doesn't stop me from getting these gains!
There we go.
They're endangered.
Yes, they're, like, an endangered species.
Alright, there we go.
I'm ready.
This is me.
This is us.
This is Defy Snoo Snoo.
Okay, but the sound guy wanted me to change.
Alright, settings, audio.
Okay, sound guy, what did you want again?
I was too busy customizing my character.
Let's see, radio down a little bit.
Also, I heard that the radio actually gets you demonetized.
So it doesn't matter even if I got like, striked by profanity or whatever.
So like, I won't be getting...
I feel like I won't be getting ad revenue at all.
So...
I definitely won't be getting any ad revenue, guys.
From this stream.
So we're gonna be in it for that.
Uhhh...
Alright, overall up.
Okay.
I'll boost up the overall.
Alright.
I hope this works.
Uhhh...
Guys, should I...
Should I...
Okay, no.
I'm gonna get to a save state.
Okay, I'm gonna save.
Quick save.
Alright, guys.
Should we play around and see...
See if I can get my cursor show up this time?
Alright, let's try.
Guys, I think...
I think we can do this.
Okay, I turned the controller off.
Where my mouse?
Controller...
Off.
Alright.
Back on.
I see.
Controller...
Off.
Alright.
It's back on.
Okay.
Let's get the subtitles on.
Might as well.
Dialogue.
General subtitles.
HUD.
Pip-Boy colors.
Uhhh...
Actor fade.
Alright.
Todd, why...
Okay,
we fucking did it.
Oh my god!
I told you, Todd is always right!
Todd!
Never doubt Todd again!
Chad!
I fucking knew giving him more money was the...
I knew giving him 40 fucking dollars was the right thing to do.
Like, of course...
He needs more money, guys.
He needs...
He has a family to support it.
Oh, and George, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And money.
Love these background music.
Alright.
Just worked.
Doubters.
You got all the fucking doubters.
Encounter legend...
Survival ads.
Okay, what is like hard?
Uh...
Legend...
You know what?
I think we can survive hard.
Okay, we're not doing very hard, but we'll do hard.
Alright.
I think it'll be fine.
It just works.
Name.
Hey, hun.
Just getting ready.
Alright.
How's the volume now?
Oh, hey!
It's my robot!
Codsworth!
Whoa!
Don't spill it on my lap!
Oh.
Thanks, Codsworth.
Thank you!
There's my sugar bombs!
100% daily value of sugar.
Oh, hey!
Alright.
Let's see.
Hey, hun.
Annie!
I can't believe it's almost Halloween.
That was Halloween?
Well, there's my newspaper!
Wait, we have two newspapers?
More of the same.
Oh, sounds like someone made a sticky.
I should attend to young Sean.
Oh, yeah.
My kid's Sean.
I'm glad we got Codsworth.
I wonder how much he cost.
Wait, what the fuck is this fridge?
Oh, my God!
It has a window!
It has a window so we can see inside!
That's so smart!
Nuka-Cola.
Ice cold.
Saddle up Salisbury steak.
That's so smart, but where do I get the ice?
At the bottom!
As someone that always forgets what's in my fridge, that is so fucking smart.
Oh, my God!
Okay, you know, I said, like, I know the intro by heart, but I literally forgot what's, like, in, like, the setting of everything because my dad just skips through so fast.
I'm so sorry.
He just speed runs to, like, to, like, getting into the vault.
I forgot what everything, the setting, the immersion was like.
Alright.
Oh, it's like, like, the vault thing!
He's selling the vault to me!
Where's the door?
Is that my door?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's the back door.
Sorry, the door should have been yellow.
Okay, I'm not gonna get in here.
Good morning!
Hello!
Wait, do I need to interact with my son?
Give me a sec.
Where's my son?
Hello, son!
Oh my God, you're so ugly!
You're clearly not Ginger.
Where are my freckles?
I told you!
They're phasing out!
My son's not Ginger!
How dare he?
Okay, there you go.
Hello?
Go on.
I can't hear you!
Urgency?
Why?
Oh shit!
He had a nuclear bomb!
Doki Doki never changes.
Wait, how would you know?
Huh?
Yeah, you're encroaching on my fucking gym time.
I've been preselected?
Wait, what?
Enough space?
I don't need to...
God, I look beautiful.
Wouldn't you have to pay for it?
I thought you had to pay.
Wait.
Tell me more.
It's like a pyramid scheme and I'm all for it.
Pyramid schemes are not a scam.
Because if you get to the top...
It's not a scam.
You just don't know how it works.
All I'm saying is that if you're at the middle tier of a pyramid scheme...
Or like the higher tier you are in the pyramid scheme...
The more money you make.
So it's not my...
So it's your fault if you don't make any.
Okay.
Sorry.
It's not a scam if you're at the top.
That's the spirit.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Uh...
Strength.
Okay.
We're gonna have it on strength.
And then...
Which one is the...
Doki Smash.
Okay.
Um...
The strongest lawyer there is.
Don't use my brains as a lawyer.
They're just fully intimidated at that point.
Okay.
Um...
What else is good?
Alright.
Now that I have 12 more points...
What else should I put?
Charisma?
Alright.
No one...
Which one's gun?
Guys.
Which one is gun?
By the way.
Um...
Oh yeah.
I should put like 5 in endurance.
Uh...
Basically...
Geog.
Guys.
I need to know which one's gun.
Is it actually agility?
Agility is for pistol?
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
I think it's perfect.
I... I honestly...
Uh...
I think...
Agility...
Agility and perception?
Alright.
There we go.
I think we're fine.
I think this is perfect guys.
Hahaha.
Look.
All we need is strength and gun.
We don't need anything else.
Worst lawyer ever.
Guys!
Did you not see me?
If I could, I'd put everything on strength.
If I could.
Hahaha.
Strength and perspective.
Look.
Do you not see my guns?
I meant my fucking two guns right here.
My left gun and my right gun.
I did not mean the other gun.
Doki smashed!
Thank you for the search chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Real female Doki.
There you go.
Wait, actually I needed like real female Doki.
Let's throw it back to 76.
Alright, accept.
Why can't I accept it?
Huh?
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
Very real.
Nice.
Yay!
We did it, honey!
We're in the vault!
Alright.
Here you go.
Cogsworth, can you say my name?
Don't worry, Cogsworth.
Mamas here.
Hey, Cogsworth.
If I may, Sean requires your personal attention.
A little motherly love to quiet the nerves.
Don't.
Don't worry.
Mama's here to love my child.
Hello, Sean.
Oh, my gosh.
Don't look down on my reputation.
camera thing will never close.
Just arms and feet.
Not a shot.
Don't talk much on the phone.
Don't hush.
Now get out there.
Okay.
You have to be smart in that.
On my.
Do what?
What?
Yeah.
The fucking hell of a neck!
What?
Press E to shine.
What is it, Cogsworth?
Where's the bomb?
Where's the mushroom?
What?
What's that say?
Let's just sit here and not do anything.
Can we die in the beginning?
No, it's happening.
Please stand by.
Who opened the door?
Who the fuck opened the door?
There's ghosts here too?
I'm not going in.
I wonder if I can actually...
Todd, from the fate of Todd himself, he opened the door.
Who cares?
Just leave!
It's life!
Oh my god, you're gonna wait for me?
What a sweet husband!
Don't worry, I'm in the program.
I literally just volunteered.
Get in.
I'm going in.
You can't start!
He's the Vault-Tec rep.
Where was...
Okay, okay.
We're not in the program.
I'm reporting this!
I'm reporting this.
Wait, he doesn't get in?
That's so fucked.
He literally like...
You need to get in.
...tried to scam me into a pyramid scheme.
But it's not a scam, guys.
Adult male.
Adult female.
Okay, go ahead.
He's in the program.
Thank you.
Good luck, sir.
And god help us all.
Go let us in.
Oh my god, look, there's the power army.
Head to the elevator.
Wait, why is your voice so high?
It should be like super low because you're in the power army.
Follow me!
Come on!
What's going to happen to all those people outside the gate?
Hey!
We're doing everything we can!
Now keep moving!
Follow me!
DarkFox, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Zoom!
Nuclear launch detected.
Excuse me.
Go, go, go!
Can I tank this?
Can I technically not die?
When will the nuclear bomb drop?
Oh, it's not going to die.
It's going to die.
It'll be fun.
Oh, that's just a show.
I thought it was like a thing.
I'm waiting.
When is it going to show up?
These guys are like, please, please, Doki.
Please open, let us in.
Wait, can I?
Wait, I should quick save.
I should.
I mean, what's the worst that's going to happen?
I die?
Look at me.
I'm pretty sure I'll just be a fucking strong ghoul.
There's no bomb.
What if it was just a false alarm?
You guys don't know that.
Guys, I bet you it's just a false alarm.
I literally have 10 durability, like 10 on strength.
And what if I become She-Hulk?
I already got like the first half of it done.
I just need a radiation part.
I...
Wait, can you actually explore the town?
Oh my God.
What if I just explore the town?
I've never actually explored the town before.
I feel like it let me because it's scripted.
Why don't they let us in?
10 strength versus...
Nah, I'd win.
I mean, I feel like...
I feel like...
Because it's scripted, you're actually allowed to like...
Guys, you weren't allowed to explore the town.
Let's go in.
We'll be okay.
Yeah, guys, we'll be okay.
What happened?
Whoa!
Oh my God.
There it is.
Don't worry.
We'll slowly go down.
Yay!
I mean, they have power armor.
They'll be fine.
How was I supposed to know?
I thought it was just a government hoax.
It was a fear tactic.
I can't believe I didn't turn into the...
I can't believe I didn't turn into She-Hulk.
Are you all right?
You all right, hubby?
Oh, yeah.
Bro, maybe I should hold the child.
I feel like your arm's gonna break any moment.
I feel like your arms are gonna break any moment.
My spaghetti-ass husband.
If we left a minute later...
No, no, don't get caught up thinking about that.
You're safe now.
Yeah, we're safe!
Everyone just head up these stairs.
And through the door there.
Hey!
Up the stairs.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, that's me!
Real female!
I thought he was calling my name.
But I was like, oh my god, he said my name!
But he was just saying female.
Real female!
Thank you.
Oh my god, you made a suit in my size?
It's so difficult finding a shirt that doesn't rip because of these guns.
Yeah, but it's better down here!
We get free food and entertainment and you'll never have to work again!
Welcome to the gun show.
Where's my new home?
Oh my god, we're gonna get Disney'd.
Just step in here and put your vault suit on.
Alright.
In front of everybody?
I mean, I'm not shy or anything.
I'm very confident about my body.
I worked hard for it.
The pod will decontaminate and depressurize you before we head deeper in the vault.
You'll live a whole new life.
Did I change?
The Doughkeeper and Fart of Swoltech.
Thank you for the super chat, Tom.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit, I looked down instead of at my husband and child.
Hello?
Don't worry, don't unfreeze me like they'll unfreeze Disney.
Oh my gosh, I'm looking up again.
That... that my husband?
Oh my god, we're gonna be let go early.
Is it time to repopulate the world?
Are we going to the surface?
Give him the child!
His fucking arms are sticks!
How can you not pull off the child?
I'm gonna give it to you, Sean!
Oh, he's dead.
Sean!
Clio Genic Seed.
Wait, I'm the backup?
Look, all I'm saying is if my husband invests in 10 points of strength, that wouldn't have happened.
I'm not gonna let you do that.
That's all I'm saying.
He invested in the wrong thing.
If he was a fucking lawyer, he could have survived.
I'm only a Plan B.
I can't believe it.
I worked so hard on these guns.
Oh!
He could have taken... exactly, he could have taken the bullet.
Cause I might...
Hello?
There has to be... a room.
How do I release it?
Wait, how are you dead?
Wait, the rest are dead as well?
Wait, how are all the rest of you dead?
Wait, there's nobody in this one.
Wait, there's only... 2, 4, 6, 8 pods?
How did you guys die?
Open!
I can't do manual release?
The freezer broke?
But how did I live through the freezer?
Oh, they li- the life support failed, but I lived.
That's why you should have invested in 10 in strength, guys.
They didn't.
I lived because of that.
You're all dead.
Alright, they didn't invest in 10 strength.
Typica.
Let's transfer.
Oh!
Wait, did I not wear my suit yet?
Oh, I must not have worn my suit.
I didn't realize.
What is my outfit?
How do I look at my inventory?
How do I look at my inventory, guys?
What's the inventory tab?
All I can do is quick save.
So fucking weak.
Is it tab?
It's not tab.
I can't open my inventory.
Oh, I can't yet.
Am I actually wearing it?
Oh, I am wearing it.
I am wearing it.
They just all watched me.
Oh, there's a Radroach.
They all just watched me change in front of them.
Security terminal.
Welcome to Robco industry.
Uh...
Vault 111 is designed to test the long-term effects of suspended animation on unaware human subjects.
That's me!
I'm unaware!
Security staff are responsible for maintaining installation integrity and monitoring science staff activity.
Under no circumstances are staff allowed to deviate from assigned duties.
Insubordination or interference with vault operations are capital offenses.
Security staff are authorized to use lethal weapons.
All right, what about the...
security logs?
What's the latest one?
Last entry.
No all clear from Vault Tech is coming.
We need to leave.
We're all but out of food.
Almost murdered Stanley for dropping a damned salt cracker on the floor.
A handful of us confronted the overseer about opening up the vault.
I never knew a man that small could shout that loud.
Now he's locked himself in his office along with the rest of the science staff.
Oh!
Okay, so everybody just left.
What date is it today?
Okay, so everybody left at like, 78.
They ran out of supplies in 78?
That's fucking crazy!
I thought like... all clear and evacuation.
Okay.
What is this?
Vault-Tec is classified short term.
Oh, it's a short term.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Oh, it's been 200 years.
Okay.
In absence of an all clear message from Vault-Tec, the overseer may elect to evacuate staff after a mandatory shelter.
They left?
Yeah, they left after only two years.
There's only supplies for two years?
How do I open my husband's thing?
I'm gonna rob him.
Where is it?
Is there no instructions to open it?
Yeah, it only like, survived for two years.
That's crazy.
Wait, the control panel is next to his pod?
Guys, I need to go back.
Wait, what's this?
I'm gonna sit down.
I need to rest my legs.
I worked only on my arms.
I didn't realize I could open his pod as well.
Because I couldn't open my own.
I couldn't open the others.
Alright, time to rob my husband.
Look, it's technically mine.
See, because I couldn't open these, so I assumed I could open his.
Alright, what do you have?
Oh, I got the wedding ring.
Nice.
I can sell it for money.
Thank you.
Thank you, dead husband.
Nice.
Now I can have extra income in the wastelands.
It's technically mine!
We shared bank accounts.
Alright.
Easy money.
Oh shit, it's time.
It's time.
This is what I've been training for.
Get over here.
Doki smash.
There's no banks in them.
Yeah, that's called inheriting.
This is exactly why I put ten in straight.
Doki smash.
Where's more?
I'm ready.
I'm gonna try and take as many stuff I can.
I can carry a lot too, because I have like, I've maxed out.
Uh, overseer memo.
Remember, use of the recreation terminal is a privilege.
If work performances decline, this privilege may be revoked.
Enjoy responsibly.
Uh, oh play tape.
Oh, I get to play a game?
What the fuck is- oh is this like Donkey Kong?
Wait, I just realized who the enemy is.
I gotta save, I gotta save my woman.
I got- Wee.
Wee.
I did it!
Yay!
Okay, let's leave.
This is top ten.
What is this?
Alright.
Oh, I know.
I just didn't think I'd get there that fast.
Oh, wait, I can drink beer?
Is there any negative- Guys, is there any negative effects to drinking alcohol?
No, right?
I keep accidentally sitting down.
I'm so tired.
Okay, I can take- I can keep the game?
How?
How do I take it?
Okay.
Oops, sorry.
Uh...
Play tape.
Oh, eject it.
Okay.
How do I- No, I can't.
It won't let me eject it.
It doesn't let me.
It says- Uh... I tried.
It says- Oh, there it is.
Oh, there you go!
I did it!
I had to, like, leave.
Alright.
Nice.
Is there anything in the fridge?
I guess not.
Any radroaches?
Any radroaches around?
No?
Does no one have any items for me to steal?
I can't believe it!
Alright, time to beat up some more radroaches.
Hello?
Radroaches?
Ah!
There you go.
Oh, shit!
Ow!
That hurts!
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow!
Sorry, I forgot.
Electricity hurts.
Doki smash!
There you go.
Nice.
Oh, do you have stuff?
Press the block.
Oh, I need a block!
Okay, I'm gonna block the electricity.
Okay.
Still can't eat yet.
It's this way.
Does that mean there's stuff here?
Press hold lower alt to power attack.
Oh, okay.
Power attack is left alt.
That's such a...
That's such a terrible button.
For power attack.
I'm gonna change that, actually.
Alright.
Quick save.
I need to, like, know what quick save is.
Alright.
Mouse 1.
Left alt.
Alright, I'm gonna put that as mouse 4.
Uh... I can't... I don't have a Pip-Boy yet, and that's why.
Do I not have a Pip-Boy?
Okay.
Sneak.
Quick save.
Quick save, I'm gonna make it...
This button is reserved?
What is it reserved for?
I don't have it reserved for anything!
Oh!
Oh, okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna put quick save as this.
Wait.
What?
Okay.
Uh... I'm gonna put that back in left alt.
And then I'm gonna put that here.
Wait.
What's... Wait, I can't do it!
It won't let me.
No!
It won't let me!
Okay.
I'm just gonna put it here, then.
I'm just not... I'm just gonna do it the other way.
Smash!
Oh, no.
A little bit of radiation doesn't hurt.
It's fine.
It's like... It's like eating a banana.
I'm a little hydrated.
Stay hydrated, everybody!
Alright.
I'm okay.
Gun!
This is it!
Alright.
Let's see.
Vault.
Overseer instructions.
Overseer's log.
Uh... Mutiny.
I wanna know about the mutiny.
A faction led by the security personnel have taken...
have turned on me.
Demanding they be allowed to leave the vault.
Idiots!
I will not open the door to be eradic...
eradicated to death out there.
I'm consolidating the remaining supplies.
Putting the staff on lockdown.
We're going to have to... start practicing.
Who deserves what little food we have left?
I've been too damn generous with the rations.
If people don't like it, well, that's for your mouths to feed.
Just let them out!
They're gonna die off.
They're gonna die anyway!
Let them...
Oh, I guess they don't want to open the vault door because then...
like everybody else is gonna get radiation.
Then fucking sit in the cryo chamber!
A little bit.
You might as well.
Wait, I wanna hear about the system's malfunctioning.
Strange issue today with Pod C3.
Subject appeared to be having heart palpitations.
Nothing life threatening, but unusual.
Realized almost too late that the pod was malfunctioning.
The cryogenic array almost started thawing her out.
We're not sure, but I suspect the hiccup involved tech's remote override systems.
May have sent an errant signal.
But to keep an eye out, I only hope their systems are reliable once we evacuate the staff.
Okay.
Let's see.
Open evacuation tunnel.
Alright.
Open it!
Open, open!
What about this?
Okay.
What's...
Oh, that's the one we read earlier.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yay!
We opened it.
Gun!
More gun!
How do we unlock this?
I want it now.
Okay, wait.
What the fuck?
How do I...
Wait, I can change my POV?
How do I change my POV?
Guys, how do...
Oh, it's middle mouse button.
Should I play as like...
Should I play third person or first person, guys?
I need lockpick?
Okay.
Which is better?
Third person or first person?
I can get it with dog meat?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
That's good.
I almost forgot the stims.
And can be favored for quick use.
Okay.
I have no idea if I want to play third or first person.
Do we want to look at her more?
Alright.
Let's go.
Okay.
Let's see.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Wait, what does it look like?
Maybe it's easier to aim in third person.
Not gonna lie.
It's like...
It's definitely...
Okay.
Maybe I was wrong.
But I gotta take this.
I'm gonna go.
It's meat though.
I hear more.
Okay.
Q for...
I mean, I don't need to reload.
Q for VATS?
It hasn't taught me that yet.
Hello?
How many doors is there?
To sneak?
You do increase damage left control.
Avoid bright light.
There.
I don't really...
It's one guy.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh shit!
Boom!
There you go.
Ow.
Alright.
Oh, Pip-Boy!
Finally I can access my inventory!
He's dead.
Let's loot him.
I wanted the forest anyway!
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can finally access my inventory.
Alright.
Nice!
Got my Pip-Boy!
That's me!
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm level one.
Uh... Oh, look at me.
That's me.
Okay, I got security, baton, apparel.
Uh, now I'm not married anymore.
Wait.
What do I look like without...
I'm very confident about my body.
Okay.
Is there like...
Perk chart.
Inspect.
How many radiation is there?
It should be fine, right?
Eleven?
That should be fine.
That's like eating a banana.
Okay, plus eleven.
That might not be like eating a banana.
That might not...
Hahaha!
Guys, I have a feeling it might not be like eating a banana.
Okay.
Guys, it's just a little...
Hahaha!
Just a little.
Ooh, look at these fucking arms, bro.
Oh my god, look at my abs!
Wait, where's my abs?
Hahaha!
Wait!
Oh, I need to press the button.
Guys, staying in like cryogenic pause like fucked up my abs, okay guys?
I just need to be a little bit more dehydrated.
Chat.
I don't know if you guys know this, but how abs are like...
How to get like really pronounced abs, you gotta be like super dehydrated apparently.
You are cycling sequence.
You are like a real female.
Stand back.
All in the arms.
Hahaha!
Why am I...
Because I am very confident about my body!
I worked so hard...
I was at gym, bro.
I worked so hard for these guys.
Look at me.
I worked so hard for it.
I might as well show off my assets.
Yeah, you need to be like dehydrated and a little...
Hahaha!
It's like a little bit starved.
Wait, I can like fall from here?
Yay!
The outside world!
Let me out!
This is better than Stellar Blade.
Hahaha!
Do you wanna change anything?
No, I'm fucking perfect.
Hahaha!
I'll take your return to the surface.
And thank you for choosing...
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you interested in any robot companions?
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome.
I'm fucking perfect.
Optimal build right there.
Peak performance, exactly.
Oh shit, you're right.
Maybe I should put my clothes back on.
I forgot about the radiation.
Hahaha!
Guys...
I would love to like show off...
Show off the goods.
But like I just remembered about radiation.
Hahaha!
God's perfect design.
Exactly.
Oh look, see the birds are okay.
Oh nice, there's supplies here.
There's supplies outside?
You're supposed to put that inside.
Oh, nice.
And this is the last known location of the caravan.
Okay.
I don't know which perspective I want to play.
Okay, we gotta take all this junk here.
Oh, it's to open the vault from down below.
Nice.
Find and kill pyro.
Start pyromaniac.
There's so many quests.
A typewriter?
What am I gonna do with a typewriter?
Oh yeah, I bought the DST.
I told you guys.
I gave Todd all my money.
Of course.
Like Todd intended.
Because I believe in him.
In his dreams.
Hahaha!
To type-doki.
God, where were you living?
In a vault?
Alright, let's steal everything.
Oh hey!
Oh, that's a broken...
system.
Please stop sitting on chairs!
Real female doki!
I think that's gonna be my new name.
Real female...
Please!
From doki FPS Vtuber to TV, Facebook, YouTube, to real female doki.
I think that's gonna be my new name now.
Hahaha!
Oh, those were all the people that were...
I like how it taught me how to run now.
That died outside.
I wanted...
Is that a person?
No, that's a tree.
That's a fucking tree.
Okay.
Where do we go?
Oh wait, there's a...
There's a person here to my left.
I assume we go this way.
Wait, is this gonna be my future home?
The sanctuary!
This is gonna be my new home!
I'm gonna like rebuild this!
Oh!
Let's find Cogsworth!
Oh my god, I can rob people.
I've never liked my neighbors anyway.
That's right, I want that lamp.
Alright, give me that fucking pot.
Oh my god, bottle caps!
We're rich!
Okay, tin can.
It's okay, my neighbors are dead.
It's ethical robbing.
I'm just being like, you know, the British Museum.
Hahaha!
James, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Cogsworth!
You're alive!
How did you survive it?
Oh my god, there's another typewriter.
Oh, I can customize my gun!
Uh...
Short barrel, comfort grip.
Ooh!
Adhesive, improved recoil and hip fire.
You might as well.
I have everything for it.
I should not be upgrading my default gun.
Nevermind.
It's just a scratch.
Alright, let's see.
There's people using the radio.
Oh my god, they know how to use the radio!
That's crazy!
Alright.
Oh my gosh, my neighbors.
Why are my neighbors so poor?
We live in suburbia!
Oh, nice bobby pins.
I found bobby pins, guys.
Nice.
There's no subtitles for radios, unfortunately.
Wait, have I turned off, like, motion blur?
I couldn't tell.
Gameplay... display.
Is there motion blur?
I don't know.
I think there isn't.
Hahaha!
It doesn't see... Oh, there we go!
Wait, is it?
No, that's fade.
I couldn't tell if there's motion blur.
Alright, let me, like...
I'm gonna, like, turn my sense a bit lower, though.
The sense was way too high for me.
There we go.
COGSWORTH!
You're alive!
It's me!
Everything's dead!
We gotta, you know, like, we gotta give it to him straight.
They did it.
All that fighting.
And for what?
Everything's dead.
Everything's dead?
Ah, yes.
The garden.
The posies have been problematic, I admit.
If only sir were here to help.
Where is he, by the by?
He's fucking dead!
He can't be dead.
Okay, I'm gonna be in denial.
He can't be.
COGSWORTH, going through the five stages of grief right now.
We can both be in denial.
Wait, can we actually romance COGSWORTH?
I know you can romance people in Fallout.
I know you can.
They stole him!
Sean's been kidnapped, COGSWORTH!
Sean's been kidnapped.
I'm gonna find him.
I'm gonna get my baby back.
It's worse than I thought.
You're suffering from hunger-induced paranoia.
What, from losing my son?
Two hundred years will do that, I'm afraid.
I feel fine.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Just a little bit of radiation.
I feel fine.
I sort of like ate a little bit of Radroach meat, but it's okay.
It's like eating a banana.
You can make me food?
How do you have food?
Wait, you okay?
Why is it yellow?
People would withhold information.
You can attempt to persuade them into sharing both.
Okay, you okay.
COGSWORTH, you're acting...
A little easy.
Orange, medium, red, hard.
Oh, okay.
Look at that!
One persuasion!
One charisma, and I'm okay.
Persuade with that one charisma.
Oh my god, he just wants to serve.
That's all he wants.
The futility of dusting a collapsed house.
Trust me.
So true!
Look at you!
You couldn't even polish yourself!
What do you know?
What do you know, Codsworth?
I'm a...
The bombs came and all of you...
I thought for certain you and your family were...
A little radiation soup as a treat.
Jay, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I thought the sir was going to present it to you as a surprise.
But then...
Well...
Everything happened!
Wait, holotape?
A holotape?
Yeah, what's on it?
I believe it's a private message for you.
My etiquette protocols would not permit me to play it for myself.
Any standard holotape reading device should be able to play it back.
Oh, like that Pip-Boy on your arm.
That should work brilliantly.
Now, enough feeling sorry for myself.
Shall we search the neighborhood together?
Sir and young Sean may turn up yet.
Yeah.
No.
Okay, yes.
Yeah, I need...
I need a companion for now.
I need him to tank damage for me.
No.
Don't get near me.
Where is the...
From the map, select map marker.
With to fast travel to hold to drag to view.
Anywhere on the map, add a custom marker.
Where is the holotape?
Where do I look at that?
Radio...
Umm...
Is this Hi Honey?
Is it this?
Why the fuck did you give me this tape?
I'm already going through trauma, Cogsworth!
Can I rob my own house?
Nice.
Nice!
Oh my god.
Please stop sitting on chairs.
I can't believe...
I can't believe it.
I'm coming, sweetheart.
Bro, he's fucking dead.
What do you mean?
I can't believe... I can't believe Cogsworth gave me more trauma.
I was trying to fucking move on.
I don't understand, Cogsworth.
Why would you do this to me?
After everything I've been through.
Feels fucking bad, mom.
Alright, we gotta...
Oh, there's more?
Did I not loot everything?
Oh wait, there is!
No, that is just a baby rattle.
That's money!
I can sell Sean's baby rattle.
I'm gonna sell everything that I've owned of Sean so like I can move on.
That's so healthy.
As long as like I pretend he never existed, I'll be okay.
I'll just sell every little reminder I have of him.
The books is on the... Did I miss the book again?
Did I...
Okay, where the fuck... Is that one right?
I couldn't... You're special!
Where's strength?
I like...
I like how it won't let me improve my strength anymore.
Alright, I guess we'll do a little bit of charisma.
I guess.
I'll do a little bit of charisma, chat.
Can't improve past 10.
No more strength.
Why would I even let me improve my strength?
Oh, dog bull.
Stop sitting!
I'm sad.
I keep sitting.
I keep fucking sitting.
My legs are tired.
Oh, Nuka-Cola.
Nuka-Cola.
Bolt fly.
Oh god.
There's way too much radiation.
I don't remember the concept, but like back then, like, cause you know how like in prehistoric times, um, the bugs were like huge, but then... I think it's like to deal with like temperature or something?
Oh shit!
How do I do this?
But like, more years passed by, the smaller the insects got.
Uh... Use A to turn the screwdriver.
If you spot... The spot is too chosen.
The lock will rotate and open.
If the lock resets, release A and reposition.
How do I do this?
...
Oh, there you go.
Ah!
I did it!
I'm so smart!
...
Nice!
Oh gosh.
There was like...
Oh, there was more!
There's so many items!
...
Oxygen!
Ah!
There isn't enough oxygen now.
That's great!
Thank... See?
Deforestation!
...
... Finally!
It's a good thing!
...
Thank God!
Alright.
Finish it, coward!
Finish what?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Got lighter...
I got these... Oh, I can turn on the... Okay.
I can't turn on the TV.
Let's see.
More metal trays...
Oh my God!
A watch!
I'm gonna loot everything.
There's so much stuff to loot!
This is great!
There's so much ethical robbing I can do.
Alright.
... Let's see.
Wait, I can... Stop!
Sitting on chairs!
... Mary, think of this...
Superchat, thank you, thank you.
The one slur wasn't really bad after all.
Exactly, Mary!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
I knew it!
I knew, like...
I knew there was a reason why I liked the one slur.
...
Wait, where's Cogsworth?
Where the fuck did he go?
Did he go here?
Oh, I see him.
He's over there.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, there's a pump?
Oh yeah, because it was Halloween!
Hello?
...
No, they're alive!
Both my husband and my child are alive!
Sean's out there, yeah!
Sean's out there, Cogsworth.
He's out there!
I need to find him.
What about Cogsworth?
...
What?
Why did you travel?
You're useless.
...
He likes it!
Guys, don't worry.
Why would he come back to get pummeled if he doesn't like it?
...
We're gonna find Sean!
We did it!
...
It's cause he likes him giving him what he wants, guys.
How dare you!
Wait, okay, I need to use the bathroom.
Let me put on the radio for you guys.
It's gonna get demonetized anyway.
Alright.
What's a good radio station?
There you go.
We'll do this.
Oh, we're back.
I'm back!
I'm back, guys.
You guys like the radio?
Alright, let's see.
Let's loot a little bit.
Guys, we have to like...
We have to find our son Sean!
...
Who's definitely very much alive.
Alright, let's see.
Where do we go?
Where's my house?
It's like this way.
Okay, we have to go this way.
...
Are we in the right place?
Oh, the water's fine!
...
Guys...
It's not fine.
...
Guys, I've discovered that it was absolutely not fine.
Guys, who would've thought?
Oh, hey.
Dog meat.
Oh, shit!
Wait, I wanna wear his clothes!
Bro, his clothes look so...
His clothes accentuate my body!
Alright, let's see.
Where is apparel?
...
Okay, let's see.
Postman hat, drifter outfit, military...
What's military fatigue?
What's that look like?
...
Oh, shit.
I'm the postman.
You're gonna fuck your wife.
...
Alright, I have a deliver...
No, mock pigtails!
Oh, no, we shouldn't have a hat.
Alright, here we go.
And then... Oh, yellow fedora.
Where did I find this?
Alright, no hat.
I need you guys to see my hair.
There we go.
Look, it shows off my build better.
I like that.
Alright, we go this way.
This is where dog meat shows up.
We need him for the gun.
That's the milkman.
Both works out too.
Don't you never heard about the postman too?
You gotta be careful with the two.
Be careful with the UPS guy.
Dog meat!
Hello, dog meat!
You okay?
You're a boss.
Where's your owner?
I'm your owner now.
...
Okay, then.
Let's stick together.
...
Wait, I wanna... Get over here!
I wanna pet you!
Wait there.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, I can trade?
Dog meat.
What the fuck?
What do you want?
Dog meat, do you want a gun?
...
Dog meat, take this gun!
Give him toys?
Like what?
The baby rattle?
I have a baby rattle.
Does he like that?
...
He's got a gun.
Oh my god!
He has a gun!
What is he gonna do with it?
Do I have a toy?
Here, have a toy car.
Uh, there you go.
Uh...
Let's see it.
Talk.
How you doing?
You wanna play tricks?
You know tricks?
How smart are you?
...
Oh my god, he's so cute!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
What else?
How you doing, buddy?
How you doing?
You wanna play fetch?
Think you can find something for me?
Uh, find me...
container?
What's a container?
You're so talented!
Oh my god, dog meat!
Why are you barking me like that?
You have a gun!
...
I gave him a gun and a toy car.
He's fucking strapped.
Oh, there's a workshop here.
Okay, we got...
I don't know which...
I'm gonna go with first person and then when we're fighting...
What the fuck?!
Where did these...
Dog meat!
What the fuck happened?
I left for like one second, dog meat!
Holy shit!
I left for one second!
Dog meat, shoot him!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
I left for one second, dog meat!
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
I went to loot!
Dog meat, no!
I'm gonna get a stim pack.
I know you can recover your HP.
You can't lie to me.
Stop faking it, dog meat!
See, you're okay.
I thought I was gonna...
You don't need a stim pack.
Don't fake it, man.
You're like...
Dog meat...
Get it.
I know he has self-heal.
He can't lie to me.
Heal your...
He's literally okay!
What do you mean?
He has self-heal!
I don't!
Wait, do I?
I don't know if I do.
Do I have self-heal?
I can't remember.
Dog... Stop!
Stop, doki!
Oh wait, no.
We need this.
Okay, safe storage.
Wait, no.
I wanna look at the safe storage.
Oh no, a dog with a gun.
Hopefully, we're not around anyone.
Sharka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dog meat is dangerous out there.
Take this.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Take care of these barrels before you leave tonight.
Inspectors are coming first thing in the morning.
Just hide them with the others.
We'll figure out long-term solutions.
Okay.
What's the last service log?
Replace the atomic alternator in a 2073.
Co-verga.
Oh hey!
Is that the car?
Okay.
Let's see.
Should we keep the radio on, guys?
Is there food in here?
No, there's no food in here.
God damn it.
Uh...
Grab this.
I still don't know if I wanna keep the...
If I wanna keep...
If I wanna play in first person.
Wait, where's my dog?
Where did my dog go?
Dog meat?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, command.
Oh, are you scared?
Follow me.
Get over here.
Where is the car though?
Is it this one?
Move here.
Here.
No, stop, stop, stop.
Stop moving.
I just want you to follow.
I'm so sorry.
I was trying to talk to you.
I didn't mean to.
I swear to God.
Oh my God.
It was an accident.
I swear.
I swear to God.
It was an accident.
Oh my God.
Where is he?
Follow me.
How do I make him follow me forever?
Do I just take him to the settlement?
I was trying to...
I was just trying to press the button.
I swear.
Hold R.
Why are you whimpering?
Why do I cancel this?
Oh my God.
He's alive.
No, he wants to...
He wants to follow me.
Follow.
See?
Come on, Doug.
Yeah, see?
Tough love.
It's all about the tough love.
I swear it was an accident.
I was trying...
Why was it...
Why was it on the head?
I would have whimpered too if I was shot.
Okay.
Let's see.
We gotta go this way, I believe.
We'll go this way.
It was an accident, guys.
It's not my fault my hands naturally...
He like went to his head.
I sw...
Oh shit!
Get that shit away from me!
Okay, where's the other bug?
Where did the other one go?
I'll be okay.
See, this is exactly why I don't give a Stimpak to the dog.
I like naturally don't have selfia.
I have to eat fucking rat roach meat to stay alive.
Open the door.
Must be loot here, right?
No, do not sit on the couch.
Oh hey, Nuka Cola!
Nuka Cola!
I hope you guys are okay that I swapped between first and third person.
I like to loot in first person, but I wanna shoot in third person.
Okay, let's see.
Grab all this junk.
Grab psycho.
What the fuck is psycho?
I'm playing on hard.
Wait, is he...
Okay.
Dog meat?
Oh, baseball bat behind the door?
What am I gonna do with a baseball bat?
There's no baseball bat, you liar.
What do you mean?
There's no baseball bat.
Sorry, dog meat.
Oh, there it is!
There must be like a way to quick shuffle in between like...
Between weapons.
Oh, there it is!
Fuck!
This is why... This is exactly why I don't play... I don't play this on...
I don't shoot in first person.
There's no crosshair.
I'm in Concord now.
Let's see.
How do I... What's that... Where's the hotkeys to swap like weapons?
Hold F?
It's not F.
Oh, there is F!
Uhh...
Nine.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
How do I... Okay, I wanna swap my weapons to baseball bat.
Uhh...
Q?
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Okay, and then F...
F9.
There you go.
I can beat up some fucking bugs with my bat.
Can I?
I can play in third person to beat people up.
Hello?
I hear gunshots.
Any... Any enemy?
Enemy?
I have to go here.
Oh shit, we're gonna help like the settlement.
The... What is it?
The Minuteman or some shit?
Soon?
I hear them.
Oh loot.
But loot though...
Purified water!
I can sell that for so much money!
Guys, I can't drink yet.
I can pick this.
I can't pick that?
No, I'm too dumb.
Too dumb.
Sucks.
I can't be dumb and fucking jacked.
Okay, nice.
Is there anything in the Nuka Cola?
Oh, there is!
Is it precedent time?
Hello?
Anyone here?
Oh shit, there they are!
Oh, there he was.
Let me loot him.
Oh my god, there's a raider's outfit!
Are you okay, Dogmeat?
Did you kill him?
Nice.
Oh my god, I'm gonna look so pretty.
Give me a sec, I'm gonna change my outfit now.
Let's see, harness... damage resistance.
Oh wait, there's like stats.
I didn't realize there's stats.
Oh, right leg.
Sack hood with straps?
What the fuck does that look like?
Oh god.
Okay, no.
We're not covering our head.
We don't need to cover our head.
Bop bop.
Alright.
Time to loot.
I should save them, but like, loot is more important.
Anything goes.
Is there fall damage?
Whoa.
Nope.
Yeah!
Alright, let me in.
Oh, there's the Minuteman outfit.
Wait, who?
Oh, there he is.
Hey there.
That's fucking right.
Whoa!
Whoops.
Can I like, beat his head off?
Oh, what's the point?
Oh my god, dude!
Dogmeat, what the fuck?
Stop!
Guys, it's not what it looks like!
I swear to god!
Guys, it was an accident!
I swear!
Guys, I swear to god it was an accident!
I swear to god!
I know, like, it happened twice, but I swear I did not mean to do it.
I know.
Fool me once, shame on you!
But I swear to god!
It's not what it looks like!
And it's not what it looks like!
I love dogs!
My best friend's a dog, guys!
Okay.
Wait, how do I... do I... it's not reloaded?
Oh, it doesn't have...
It doesn't have ammo.
There we go.
I was like, why isn't it not hitting?
Let's see.
Gotta loot while everything is going on.
There's so much stuff going on that I can loot.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I have to reload ev... oh my god, I do!
I do!
I do have to reload every shot.
That fucking sucks.
Oh, there's an enemy in front of me.
I can see him.
I can see him on the map.
There we go.
Easy headshot.
Where's the other guy?
Where is he?
He's like, in my view, but where?
Let me grab his stuff though.
Nice.
What?
What are you gonna do?
Shoot me?
Can I open this?
God damn it, I'm too stupid.
Don't you hate it when you're just too stupid?
He does up the clippers...
Make a...
No!
Don't make a compilation!
Guys, I swear!
It was an accident!
Trevor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Select a potential password with mouse 1.
If your chosen password is incorrect, that match...
will be displayed on screen.
What the fuck am I looking at?
Error?
I can't tell if I...
Oh!
What?
Okay.
Entry denied.
So not could.
Uhhhhhhhhhhhhh.
This?
Error?
I'm so confused.
How many words were right?
Did it tell me how many words were right?
Wait, which one did I play?
Okay, I clicked could.
And it says one word.
How about owner?
Zero.
Okay, so it's not...
Umm...
Okay, so one letter was right in could.
So there's no O's in the word.
So there's no O's.
That's that we know.
That's that we know there's no O's.
And then there's no...
There could be a D.
So it could be sand.
It could be sands.
Or it could be spied.
Cause...
Sands, spied...
Build...
Uhh...
There's no O.
Okay, sand, spied...
Build...
It's the letter in the same spy?
It's letter and position.
Oh, it's letter and position.
Ohhhhhhh!
Okay, okay.
Alright, so...
Couldn't be spied because there's no E.
So it could still be sand then.
Right?
Let's say...
2, 4, 5.
No, cause it's like the fifth.
So it can't be sand.
2, 4, 5.
It could be spied!
Oh wait, no.
We just...
It could be build.
It could be build for the D.
Because like...
Could had one likeness.
And it could be like the D at the end.
Right?
Like...
Build or third.
Okay, we're gonna try build.
Likeness.
Okay, it's one more.
So it could be...
It's third.
Okay, so...
Build.
It's not...
Guys, I'm not locked out.
Guys, I'm not smart enough.
Oh, we're set for 10 seconds!
Guys, we can wait it out.
Guys, it's okay.
We can wait it out.
Alright, I got this.
Guys, I got this!
Oh, it's a new one!
Okay, we'll do...
I got leveled up!
For failing!
I love leveling up for failing!
Lying.
Zero.
Okay, there's no L, Y, I, and G.
Okay.
Melba spend.
There's one.
Okay.
So it's...
Okay, so there's one likeness.
There's one likeness.
So...
So it could be like...
It could be D again.
It can be D again.
It could be...
Bonds!
It's not N, that's for sure.
Okay, look.
There's spend.
Alright, so...
Two, four...
It could be...
The last has to be a D.
Two...
Okay, wait.
Two, four, five.
Okay, it's the fifth.
Is there any...
Spends?
It's not...
There's no more.
Okay.
So...
It's either...
It's either S, P, E, or N.
Oh, they're shady?
We're shady!
No, that's four!
Because like, it's the fifth!
Alright, let's try...
Let's try...
Let's try shady.
There's two like this!
Okay!
It could be S, A...
It can't be D.
It could be D though.
Oh, no.
Wait, can I just lockpick this?
Guys, I'm just gonna lockpick this.
Let me be...
No!
It's okay.
My bobby pin is...
No!
It's okay.
Oh, no.
We did it!
No.
Yay!
Can I still do this?
Okay, let's...
We unlocked it anyway.
Okay.
Anyway.
So, alright.
So, we figured out...
Okay.
There's one like this.
And...
Alright.
So, there's one like...
Okay.
Now, it's just...
Out of pride.
Now, it's just out of pride.
Pride now.
Alright, range.
There's one likeness.
Okay, it could be faces.
There's zero, so it's not A.
We know it's not A because like, none of us match.
So it's either R, N, G, or E.
So, alright, there's no other... there's an R here.
We could try to rely.
I did it!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We unlocked... guys, I fucking knew it, guys.
God, I'm so fucking smart.
There's nothing in... oh, there's a power core.
There's a fusion core.
Let's go.
I did it, guys.
I fucking knew I wasn't that stupid.
I knew it.
There's hope for you all.
If I can solve that, you can all solve it.
Where do I go?
There's so many places to go.
Okay, oh, scalpel.
Nice.
I learned WURTLE.
I've never played WURTLE before.
This is like... this has to be like...
the very first time I've ever played WURTLE.
Chat.
This actually is the very first time.
What's that?
Somebody here.
Oh shit!
It's like, where's his head?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Give me a sec, I'm reloading!
Guys, it's so nice.
He actually like...
Guys, it's so good.
He actually like fucking...
waited until I...
He waited until I reload.
Isn't that great?
People are so like...
They're so polite.
People are so polite that they waited for me.
He was so polite.
Exactly.
Is there anybody here that I can shoot?
I hear people reloading.
But I have no idea where they are.
Alright, let's go up.
It's time to go up.
Dog meat.
Oh, there he is.
Peek me!
Peek me, bitch!
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
What did he...
Wait, there's more?
Dog meat, please bite him!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, I saved him!
Don't say I didn't do nothing.
I saved him.
He was about to get kicked, but I stopped him.
There we go.
Did I get like double?
Nice.
There we go.
Oh shit, I leveled up!
How do I...
Alright, nice.
Can I...
The first thing I do is like...
Can I do more strength?
Channel your chi to unleash...
Crunching attacks.
Your quick hands make pocketing easier.
Toughness...
Let's see.
Let Vault-Tec guide you.
The path you're closest is displayed.
In VATS.
Oh, I like that!
Through chemistry.
Yeah.
Confirm.
Accept.
I want that.
What else can I do?
I'm called Racket69 and I...
Should I put more in?
Fortune finder?
Whoa!
Can I... I should do more gunslinger.
I should do gunslinger.
Yeah.
It's all about the guns.
Do I have more?
No.
Alright, we got gunslinger.
And...
Useless perk.
What do you mean useless?
What do you mean?
Bro, the worst perk?
Which one was the...
What?
The VATS?
Guys, you don't understand.
I'm always lost.
I don't think it's useless.
I don't think it's useless, guys.
You just don't understand.
You don't appreciate the little things in the world.
Okay, nice.
We got to take his clothes.
Is he enemy?
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
That would be so unfortunate if I killed an essential NPC.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, hey.
Alright, this way.
If you don't use it...
I'm going to use it all.
Just wait and see, guys.
I'll let you in on a little dirty little secret.
You can get more stats above 10 if you use the boost.
Actually, just don't get addicted.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Preston Garvey.
Commonwealth Minuteman.
Oh, wait.
What?
Talk to me.
Minuteman?
So now I'm traveling backward in time.
Protect the people at a minute's notice.
That was the idea.
So I joined up.
Wanted to make a difference.
And I did, but...
things fell apart.
Now it looks like I'm the last Minuteman left standing.
Wait, you're the last one?
What happened?
What about the people around you?
Are they Minuteman too?
Who are these people?
Just folks looking for a new home.
A fresh start.
I've been with them since Quincy.
Lexington looked good for a while, but the ghouls drove us out of there.
The ghouls?
A month ago, there were 20 of us.
How many now?
Yesterday, there were eight.
Now we're five.
They just left you, right?
They didn't die, right?
Time to eat dinner.
And this here is Sturgis.
Hey.
Okay.
It's a cruel...
Sounds rough, buddy.
Sorry.
Sounds really rough.
Thanks.
It's good to meet someone who really cares.
Anyway, we figured Concord would be a safe place to settle.
Those raiders proved us wrong.
But...
Well, we do have one idea.
Nope.
Tell me.
I'm being assertive.
There's a crashed vertibird up on the roof.
Old school.
A what?
You might have seen it.
Well, looks like one of its passengers left behind a seriously sweet goodie.
We're talking about...
I'm munching pizza.
T-45 power armor.
Military issue.
Oh, power armor.
I like it.
Yeah, I thought you might.
Protection with an added bonus.
Get the suit.
You can rip the minigun right off the vertibird.
No raiders getting express tickets to hell.
Sturgis, tell her!
Are you still telling her?
Minigun.
And I can use the minigun like a rifle.
Don't see why not.
It'll have a manual trigger.
Just aim it at the bad guys and do the old spray and pray.
Now, as for the armor, it's out of juice.
Probably has been for a hundred years.
It can be powered up again.
But we're a bit stuck.
Hmm?
I'll help you.
I have a fusion core.
A standardized fusion core.
Your high-grade long-term nuclear battery used by the military and some companies way back when.
And we know right where to find one.
But we can't get to the damn thing.
It's down in the basement.
Wait, I got it!
Security gate.
I have it right here.
I fix stuff.
I tinker.
Bypassing security ain't exactly my forte.
Wait, I'm smarter than Preston!
Guys, I'm smarter than him.
I already have it.
I already grabbed the fusion core.
We're set.
Well, all right.
Maybe I'll look...
You guys gotta say I'm not smarter.
I'm smarter than this fucker.
Jack the core into the power armor and grab that minigun.
Those raiders will know they picked the wrong fight.
Good luck.
I did it, guys.
I did it.
You okay?
What's going on?
Careful, kid...
Are we getting out of here?
Mama Murphy.
Hello, Mama Murphy.
Oh, I didn't give him her name!
Just look at you.
Dogmeat?
He's a good boy.
He's a good dog.
Smart too.
Oh, indeed.
Dogmeat's good at finding folks who need him.
And he'll stick by you now.
See?
Saw it.
You saw it?
You saw it.
It's the chems, kid.
They give old Mama Murphy...
Oh, she ain't... She's not been okay for a while.
...as long as I can remember.
The sight?
What's the sight?
I can see a bit of what was and what will be.
And even what is...
Oh yeah, where's Sean?
Where's my kid?
I
can see this something coming.
Are they all bulletproof?
Just like, I need to be sure.
If I don't want to accidentally...
What?
Oh, it can't be me.
I'm perfect.
What is it?
What?!
How did it fail?
Look at me!
Might as well be intimidation!
...when I tell you it ain't a radar.
But
I'm tired now.
What?
Even me and my one charisma didn't persuade her!
You have a job to do.
I don't understand!
Me and my one charisma should have worked!
You alright?
Oh hey, there's a Pip-Boy.
Oh, you're a person?
It's been permanently creased by one!
Yay!
No, no, no, no!
No Rhys?
There's two...
Where do I go now?
Oh yeah, we gotta go up.
How do I go up?
Let's see... Do I still want the radio on or should I turn it off, chat?
Oh yeah, it's two now.
There's literally no Rhys.
Alright, loading.
Radio on?
Alright, we'll keep it on.
It's not too distracting, right?
It's crazy that you have this little wrist.
You mean putting it all on straight was not the right idea?
No way.
That can't be true.
All those gym bros told me it was cool.
That's how you get on the ladies.
My god, the loading time is fucking insane.
Michael, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should raise your endurance to 5 then get Aqua Girl.
Water can't hurt your radiation anymore.
Only if you drink it you can swim.
Okie dokie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this loading time?
What the fuck?
No, it's moving.
See?
Look.
I told you.
It's moving.
It's night time now?
Is this canon?
Or did I just take too long?
Alright, here we go.
Oh shit.
I got the mini gun.
Ok, we gotta grab the scissors.
Am I getting shot at?
It's ok.
We're fine.
Look at my mini gun though.
Wait, where's the power armor?
Wait.
It's over here?
Where am I supposed to... Wait, give me a sec.
Dogmeat, please.
I need to go down.
There's something over here.
Oh, there's... whoops.
Guys, I forgot to... I missed the... I thought that was a person.
I legitimately thought... I legitimately thought that was a person so I walked past it.
Don't worry.
I got my power armor now.
Wait, where's Daria?
I got my mini gun.
Doki, smash!
Wait, is that... Ok, I was gonna say it.
I hope I didn't accidentally shoot the wrong person again.
Doki is ready to smash!
Get over here.
Where is he?
I'll loot you.
Nice.
Wait, what's that sound?
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, it's ok.
It's ok.
I can't shoot it.
I have so much strength.
Oh, I can take this.
Oh!
It's alright.
If I just... Oh, shit!
Bro!
Wow!
He's fucking beating me up.
Oh, shit!
Dogmeat, do something!
Oh!
Oh, guys, I don't feel ok.
I don't... Guys!
I don't feel ok, guys.
Guys.
What's my stim pack?
0.
Ok.
Alright,
so what I learned...
What I learned is that...
Death Claws.
I forgot how strong Deathclaws are, guys.
That was...
That was a little bit of a skill-tiff there.
It's okay.
Round 2.
Rematch time!
It's okay.
This is why we have Round 2.
Weeeee!
Where is he?
This is just like the Fallout 2.
Oh wait!
You're right!
VATS!
What was VATS again?
What button activates VATS?
It never taught me.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Why is this guy not taking damage?
That was a lot of bullets.
Alright, don't worry.
He's gonna boost out here.
There we go.
Alright.
It's Q or...
Alright, give me a sec.
Just reloading.
There he is.
He's coming over now.
I hear him.
There he is.
Alright, don't worry.
He doesn't see me yet.
He doesn't see me.
Do you think he sees me?
I don't think so.
DARVIK, NOOOO!
Oh my god.
Oh, 69!
69!
Where's the head?
There's a belly?
HEAD!
Oh, no.
Shoot!
E.
Guys, I should've fucking did 69.
I...
Oh...
No!
Not the raider!
Oh!
No!
Not the suplex!
Oh my god!
You can't go in the building!
He's too thick!
That's fucking right.
I know you can't enter the building.
You're way too fucking thick.
That's fucking right.
I knew it.
What you gonna do?
You're way too wide for this building.
What the fuck he glitched in?
That's illegal!
He actually glitched in!
He glitched in?!
TIE!
WHAT?!
He got in.
Oh jeez.
He actually forced himself in.
All these things.
TIE.
He had TIE cheese.
Oh my god!
He pulled it off.
He fucking no-clipped inside the door!
How the fuck did he do that?
Oh my god!
That's actually crazy that that happened!
I did not...
I just casted Q.
It just works.
I didn't think that was possible!
I didn't think you could actually noclip inside!
Oh my god, fuck this.
I'm just gonna...
Then I'm gonna run.
I'm gonna run.
It just works.
Okay.
Apparently it's belly.
Alright.
Guys, do you think I hit it?
Oh my god!
I can't believe he forced himself inside!
No!
Where the fuck is this belly?
Head.
Belly.
Pew!
Oh!
I'm gonna do this again!
It's gonna work this time!
There's no way.
There's no way he'll clip in again.
There's no fucking way.
Wait, he's gone.
Wait, did I despawn him?
I did it.
I despawned him.
What?
Hahaha!
Nice.
Oh my god, I did it!
He just left!
Guys, he just fucking left!
What the fuck happened?
He ran off.
He knew.
He was so...
Wooo!
Shit!
He bit!
Oh my god!
Bro, he fucking left again!
He fucking...
It's like...
It's like fucking... I see you!
It's like green light.
It's green light, red light!
Bro, he's flipped a car!
Oh my god, you just know...
There's no way you're gonna phase through that door again!
There's no fucking way!
You're gonna do that to me again!
Hahaha!
He's on predator mode.
Wait, where did he go?
Okay, nice.
He's only...
I don't even...
I can't see... Oh, there's my ammo.
There's no way.
There's no way I'm going up the stairs.
There's no way I'll cheese him.
Get fucking cheesed!
You fucking whore!
Okay.
Nice.
There you go.
I'll shoot him from here.
I'm not scared of cheesing.
Alright, reloading.
Not even...
It's in for the hunt!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where did he go?
He's in predator mode again.
I hate it when he does this!
Just fucking show up and let me shoot you!
Like...
Where did he go?
He's in predator mode again!
Where did he...
Hahaha!
Get up, dogmeat.
I know you have self-heal.
I don't like this.
I don't know where he is.
No, don't whimper!
Makes me sad when you whimper!
Okay.
I know you're just...
Oh, no.
There he is.
I have too much junk in my fucking inventory now.
Oh, no.
Okay, wait.
I just gotta eat.
If I eat, it'll be okay.
Alright, let's get some...
Oh, hey.
It gives me like...
It makes me smarter.
You know what?
I can eat a little bit of a...
...roll.
Okay, let's see.
0.5, 0.1...
Alright, we need to get rid of stuff.
We need to start getting...
...rid of stuff right now.
Okay, let's see.
The iron.
Oh, that's like plus two.
Okay, we gotta... How do I throw this away?
Drop.
Alright, we're gonna drop this.
And then...
No, we do not put out our pistol.
Hahaha!
Wait, where's my minigun?
Oh!
Hahaha!
I never dare doki to go to...
...fist fight the Deathclaw.
Treasure, thank you for the...
...akasupa.
Thank you.
Okay, give me...
...a sec, guys.
I need to...
...figure out how to...
Where is he?
Where's my...
...minigun?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I shot him.
Where is he?
Oh my god!
Okay, we're gonna fist fight him.
When he's a little lower.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Bro, he tried to fist fight my...
...dog!
Don't worry, guys.
Alright, you guys ready?
I'm ready.
Wait, how do I... Okay, I'm ready.
This is it.
I've trained...
...for this.
This is it.
Fight me.
I got you one HP.
It's time.
Hahaha!
I got you one HP.
It's fucking time.
Get over here, Deathclaw.
Bro, he came back!
Oh!
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Guys, I think I made a mistake!
Guys, I absolutely...
...made a mistake, but what if I just...
...fight him here?
Oh my god!
Okay.
It's okay.
How does he have a longer range than me?!
Oh!
How does he...
He has a longer range!
It's not fair!
Oh!
Guys, I'm running out of stims.
I'm running out of stims.
Have you seen it?
Have you seen his arm?
This is gonna work.
This is for the Akasupa.
Oh my god!
This is not okay!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Okay, don't worry.
I can do this.
Come back.
I got this.
I'm gonna use VATS for my fist.
Boom.
Oh!
Did
it!
Hahaha!
There we go.
We might have used a lot of our stims, guys.
The combo.
We fucking did it.
We lost a lot.
But we did it.
Not even close.
I definitely have like zero stims.
Hahaha!
This is John Cena!
Alright, it was worth it.
It was fucking worth it, guys.
Yeah, I don't have stims anymore, guys.
I don't have stims anymore.
Hahaha!
Um.
Alright, Doki smash.
I knew investing in strength was the way to go, guys.
I fucking knew it.
Alright, we gotta get rid of stuff.
We actually have too much junk now.
Uhhhhhhh.
But what can we get rid of?
Everything is so important!
Everything is so important though!
5-4?
Nice.
I don't know what to get rid of.
Okay, we could get rid of...
Bro, all these guns are so important!
Eat the food?
Okay, wait.
But the food won't help!
Get rid of the power armor?
Do I just take off my armor?
Okay, a pair of...
Where is it?
How do I get out of it?
Do you really need five?
Yes!
Hahaha!
Okay, maybe you're right.
Maybe I should...
Okay, I'll get rid of one!
Alright, fine!
Fine!
Alright, there you go.
I'll get rid of it!
Alright, nice!
Now I can loot!
Where was I supposed to go?
Did I go back?
Oh, I have to go back!
Okay.
Hello guys!
I'm back!
Back to the loading screen!
Are you not entertained?
I fist-fighted a monster and I lived!
Andrey, I'll give you a five!
Give the ships!
Thank you!
I did it guys!
Oh, hey!
More guns!
More loot!
Oh yeah, you saw me run away and then came back to beat him up!
That's me!
Is everyone okay?
Everything you've done, thank you.
Oh shit!
Fusion Cell!
And he gave me money!
I'll take it!
You've spoken like a true merc.
Well, if you ever feel like fighting for something other than yourself, you should meet up with us in Sanctuary.
Pay me!
I don't do things for free!
You don't get things done.
Doing what?
What would I need to do?
Yeah.
You need to save your life.
Stay strong like you've been.
Cause there's more to your destiny.
There is?
I've seen it.
And I know your pain.
Destiny?
What's that bullshit?
What do you mean?
You are a woman out of time.
Out of hope.
But all is not lost.
My son's alive?
What's his name?
He's alive.
Bullshit.
You're trying to play me for a fool.
Yeah.
What's my son's name?
The sight's sometimes foggy.
But it ain't ever a liar.
Your son's out there.
And even I don't need the sight to tell you where you should stop.
Sounds like a scam.
Like fortune tellers.
The great green jewel of the commonwealth.
Diamond City.
That's where the radio's from.
Diamond City?
What's in Diamond City?
Is Sean there?
Look kid.
I'm tired now.
I'm tired?
Wow!
The sight will paint a clearer picture.
Gotta give him an addiction.
Gotta feed this to get you.
Why do they always do this to me?
They give me like a sneak, a tippet.
No.
I'm not a tippet.
Let me in.
She needs to hook up.
Alright folks.
Thanks to our friend here.
It's safe to move out.
We're heading for that place Mama Murphy knows about.
Sanctuary.
That's my house!
You mean she had one of her visions while she was stoned out of her gourd.
Wait that's my house!
Y'all pay rent for that shit.
Better plan than Mama Murphy saw it.
Hold on.
Everybody just take it easy.
We're all in this together.
Right?
So Marcy.
You got a better idea of what we should do next?
Yeah what do we do next?
What do we do next Preston?
Sanctuary it is.
Let's just hope it lives up to its name.
Wait what I do?
I wanna talk!
Don't worry.
I'll get these people to Sanctuary.
We need to keep moving.
What the fuck?
They're heading to my place!
I wanted to pay rent!
We gotta have a rent agreement!
We need to have an agreement!
Look I am the sole survivor of that neighborhood.
So that makes me queen of the neighborhood.
That's how it works in suburbia.
I am the HOA.
I am the new HOA.
I am the new landlord now.
If everybody else is dead.
That makes me the president of the HOA.
Cause I'm the last person to be.
I am the last one.
I like how like...
The radio is still playing.
But this fucking loading screen is forever.
Like what?
Alright.
We need to keep moving.
Oh my god.
I'll wait for you at the Sanctuary.
I'm gonna...
Yes.
You guys are gonna be there regardless.
Oh shit.
Another loading screen.
Whoops.
You know what?
I feel like by the time I get there by walking.
The loading screen will be over.
I feel like.
Not gonna lie.
Is he here?
He's not here.
Is he actually gonna take that long to get here?
Oh my god.
Where is he?
People yet?
New friends.
I made a few new friends.
Can't have enough of those these days.
I realize that I'm no Mr. Gutsy.
But if needed.
I'd be Commonwealth.
Oh.
Is he good?
Your preference?
As you wish, Mom.
No.
Not now.
Is he a good companion?
Kinda.
What does he do?
Hey Codsworth.
Shall I?
Alright.
Let's sleep.
We need to find a bed.
Where the fuck is a bed?
He can wear a hat?
Oh my.
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
That's actually very tempting.
Alright.
Let's try Codsworth out.
Where is he?
Where the fuck did he go?
What the fuck?
How could you walk so far?
What's that?
No power?
Oh shit.
No power.
Alright.
We'll just leave this here.
Codsworth.
We're gonna make you come over.
Shall I accompany you?
I want you to wear a funny hat.
I'd like to trade some items.
Wait.
How do I make him wear a hat?
Do I have hat?
Where's hat?
Hat, hat, hat, hat.
Hat.
Are you gonna wear it?
Store?
Wait.
No.
Where's the hat?
Does he wear a hat if I give him a hat?
Give him a hat.
Oh.
Give it to him?
Okay.
Uh...
Where's the hat?
I've been lied to.
I can't believe it.
I was lied to.
He doesn't wear a hat.
He only wears a bowler hat and you have preferences?
Yes.
Of course.
Right behind you, mom.
Oh no!
Your mistress is in good health.
Oh my god.
He whimpers.
You just live in Sanctuary Hills.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, bro.
If I accidentally shoot the robot, no one will complain.
It's for the sake of both of us.
Okay.
Let's see.
We need to find a chair to sit down.
Or...
Conwards taller too.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's see.
We gotta wait.
Oh, it is real time.
Okay.
Five hours.
Alright.
I waited.
I sat on this chair and waited.
Are you there now?
Did you walk over here yet?
Are you just finding that out?
Where is he?
Oh, he finally made it.
Fucking finally.
Holy shit.
Excuse me.
Hey.
Good to see you again.
I was hoping you'd show up.
I should have listened to Mama Murphy all along.
Pretty nice place she's found for us.
I think we could settle down here.
Found for us?
This is my place!
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna make sure... Apparently, we have to take back the fusion core so it doesn't get stolen.
Where's the fusion core?
Where the fuck did the fusion core go?
I'm gonna steal.
No!
I'm carrying too much!
I already used it up.
Cogsworth, carry this!
Cogsworth, I need you to carry...
I need you to carry all my heavy shit.
Where is it?
Okay, where...
Oh, it was used up!
Oh!
Okay, where's the, like...
Okay, wait.
I need him to carry all my useless stuff.
So, like...
I'm... I'm carrying way too much stuff right now.
Alright, let's see.
Where's the... Where did I put the...
Oh my god, there's so many things.
T45.
Sort by weight?
I can sort by weight?
Where?
Oh, Z!
Okay.
Sort by...
Is this by weight?
I can't tell.
Oh, here it is.
Yeah, take all of this.
Take all of that.
Nice.
Okay, then...
Is it by weight?
I can't tell.
By inventory.
Weight is three.
Oh!
Yep, there it is.
This has to be...
That has to be... Alright.
We got the minigun out of the way.
I don't know if I'm sorting by weight right now.
Things that's sorted by damage?
I can't tell!
It doesn't tell me!
Which one?
Wait, now it's weight?
I can't tell!
Okay, 12.6...
10...
9... Oh, this is weight!
This is weight!
Okay, drifter's outfit.
You take this.
And then you take this.
And then... There you go.
That should be nice.
Thank you for carrying my stuff.
He's like my little...
He's like my caddy!
Hello.
Anyway, I am glad you're here.
Wait, did I fuck up the conversation?
But I've got another favor to ask.
I've had word from a settlement asking for help.
What?!
Still hoping there are Minutemen out there.
Somewhere.
The only chance to start rebuilding the Minutemen is to show people that they can count on us when they need us.
Trouble is, I've got my hands full here.
Do you think you can go help out the settlement?
What?
Have to?
Okay.
I was hoping for a chance to rescue some more helpless villagers.
It's not that people are helpless.
They just need someone to give them a helping hand sometimes.
That's what the Minutemen are supposed to be all about.
I don't wanna be a Minuteman.
You guys do it for free.
Talk to Sturgis.
I'm sure he'd be glad for all the help he can get.
Alright.
Hey there.
You ask me, freedom's always worth fighting for.
But what if I just wanna settle?
Do I have meds for you?
Yes, I was literally born here.
My energy?
What do you mean?
I told you before, kid.
I saw you leave that icebox.
I know your pain.
This world is...
Which faction's the best?
Okay, let me rephrase this.
This faction gives you the best stuff.
I don't care about more than that.
We don't need the good ending.
Wait, here you go.
Here, have some chems.
How much a companion- He likes me!
Because you're always with fear and suspicion.
But you'll find it.
You'll find that heart that's gonna lead you to your boy.
Oh, it's...
Oh no!
If I refuse Preston too much, he'll refuse to travel with me.
That's what you need to do, kid.
Follow my heart?
I gave you chems and you told me to follow my heart?
Phew.
Wow.
That took more out of me than usual.
I'm gonna need to rest now, kid.
What the fuck is that advice?
You want the best stuff?
You need ballistic armor.
Get that from the railroad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where's Preston?
What kind of advice was that?
I could just watch a Disney movie for that shit.
Follow my fucking heart and I give you like 100...
Like 100 botocast worth of chems?
What do you need?
Aren't you used to it?
No.
Okay.
Okay, I changed my mind.
Yeah, I changed my mind.
Why can't you do it?
I can help to build beds.
Look, we got a lot on our plate.
And we've been on the run for weeks.
We need food, water, shelter...
The institute lets me teleport?
You asked how you could help.
Bro, I might as well join the institute.
Did you mean it or not?
Who needs walking?
Yeah, sure.
I'll give you guys bed.
Okay.
Good deal.
Just make sure we can sleep with a roof over our heads.
Some of these old houses still look solid enough to do the trick.
There's a workbench over there you can use.
Give me a holler if you need anything.
METI battle!
Better power armor?
And liberate prime with a brotherhood and free helicopter rides?
Yeah, but I can teleport.
Thank you for the superchat METI.
Thank you.
Move options with arrow keys.
Press to find the object you wish to build.
To build its first went, try adjusting your location.
Okay.
I can build like...
I can build objects now.
Alright.
I can build a chair.
They need a bed, right?
Okay.
Raider, cages, structures, furniture.
Alright, they need a bed.
Alright, here.
Have a fucking bed.
Uhh...
Is that enough?
20% happiness?
Why are you sad?
I gave you a fucking bed!
Wait, I can give him a sleeping bag?
Oh my god, you guys should have told me that earlier.
What the fu-
Why didn't you tell me that earlier?
That's so much better!
Okay, wait.
Uhh...
Where's the beds?
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
You sleep on- you get to sleep- oh wait, can I put this under?
There you go.
One lucky person.
One lucky person can sleep under this bed.
Alright, and then...
In the house?
It'll be fine!
Nature!
Look up in the sky!
You know?
You get to like- you get to like look up and see the wonderful stars.
The bunk bed.
Exactly!
It's bunk bed time.
Fine!
You sleep here.
Sleep next to the toilet.
Alright.
Nice.
Uhh... paintbrush removed?
Let's see...
Umm... and then... I don't know.
Sleep here.
Wait, I can put it here?
Somebody will figure out how to get in there.
And the lucky person gets to sleep on this bed.
Ooh, this is my bed right here.
Hahaha!
One lucky person, i.e.
me, gets to sleep on this bed.
Let's go!
That's where I'm gonna be sleeping.
And I'm next to the toilet and the showers!
Yay!
Hehehehehe!
Wooo!
That's me!
My privilege!
Alright.
Well, to open the wall in the build area...
What?
Oh, I can like build other stuff here.
My dad loved the workshop part of this.
So then use food, water, a bed and shall increase yourself by providing each cellar with all the basics.
Do I have to?
What if I don't?
Stay sharp.
Don't let your guard down.
How do I assign people?
Hey there.
I knew Sturgis would find something to keep you busy.
Wait, I can assign people stuff?
How?
A cellar with all the basic necessities.
It says unassigned.
What the fuck is he gonna do?
Once the basic necessities are all increased, the overall happiness by raising the settlement's defense rating, this will reduce the chance that your settlement will be attacked.
My settlement's gonna be attacked?
Wait, cages?
For what?
Arenas?
What the fuck is this?
There's like arenas and everything?
Oh, there's crafting!
Oh my god!
They can make stuff?
Stores?
What are the stores gonna do for me?
Okay, resources, water, food.
Do I have to give them- Oh!
Like I can build this!
No, I don't have concrete.
Oh, never mind.
I can't build this.
Can I build food stuff?
No, I'm broke.
Okay... how about defense?
Power?
Oh, I have power!
What do I...
Power time.
I can build a generator.
I don't know what it's gonna do, but I can build it.
Oh, this builds five!
Alright.
I don't know what that does.
But it's there.
Scrap the town.
Okay, I'm gonna scrap my stuff.
How do I scrap?
How the fuck do I scrap?
Transfer?
Guys, how do I scrap my stuff?
How do I do that?
I have so much junk.
Like, look at this.
Transfer all junk.
Point at rubble and there's option to scrap.
Oververse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Plenty of follow-up for what's the over-under.
Allowing yourself to be constantly sidetracked by the Miniman.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, transfer.
Store all junk.
Oh, okay.
Transfer.
Store all junk?
Whoa.
That's a lot of junk.
Alright, what do I do after that?
Then press T?
I did it.
And then what?
Now scrap it?
Where?
Did I press V?
How do I scrap?
That's it?
And then you're good?
Do I have everything?
Oh, it does it automatically?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
I should be able to get resources now, right?
No, I'm still...
I still don't have steel.
Okay, I don't have carrots.
I can make...
Oh, I can make a scavenging station and a bell?
What the fuck am I gonna do with a bell?
Then look at the item to scrap?
How do I scrap my items?
Raider cages.
Uh...
Now scrap the town with R.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna do it.
We don't need trees.
Alright, we'll scrap this house.
Let's see.
Concrete!
Oh my god!
We don't need houses!
Whoa!
Alright.
And then...
I should be able to build resources now.
Alright, power, resources...
Does this require power?
It produces water.
Okay, you guys can have water now.
Congratulations!
And then...
They have water.
I guess I should give them food.
Resources...
Can I produce anything?
No?
Can't build anything.
Does this not require power?
What else requires power?
Power, connector, power light, power miscellaneous, local gates, manufacturing, power, neon...
Oh my god!
But what if I have a neon sign?
Uh...
D for Doki.
This is mine.
There you go!
I did it!
Does this work?
Is it on?
Why isn't it on?
D for Doki Town!
How do I connect it?
I have a generator right here!
Turn on!
Power!
Power of my fucking town!
I gotta connect the power?
I have to be an electrician?
Oh my god.
Bro, what?
How the fuck do I fucking place this?
Okay.
Um...
How?
I'm fu- A conduit?
What the fu- I don't understand.
Hahaha!
Do I just...
place this?
Is it connected?
I can't tell!
Okay here is a conduit.
Okay.
I got the conduit.
There we go.
Are you connected?
Hey!
Are you connected now?
Oh, wow.
Wire them?
How do I put a wire?
Go over to the generator.
Oh!
Oh my god, I'm doing it!
I'm doing it!
Get in!
Okay.
Is it not...
connecting?
Why is it not connecting?
I need another conduit?
I need a... Oh my god.
Okay, conduit.
What kind of conduit do I need?
Put wire on the D?
I can put wire on the D?!
Of course I can.
Get the wire and put it on the D.
You guys lied to me.
I can't attach it anywhere.
Build something that... Where can I attach this?
Be careful!
Don't get electrocuted!
What the fuck is this for?!
I can't believe it.
I couldn't put the wire on the D.
It's too far!
Do I need another one?
Wait.
Guys, we're slowly learning how to be an electrician.
We're just... It's just very slow.
No!
I don't have...
Okay.
We don't have enough copper!
I give up.
This town doesn't...
Fuck this town.
I give up.
This town doesn't need it.
Who fucking cares?
Guys, I fucking... I give up, man.
I fucking give up.
This is too difficult.
No way.
This is way too difficult to understand.
I'll figure this out another time.
My brain isn't working today.
Or tomorrow.
Wait.
Why can't I open my...
Pit boy?
Where's my pit boy?
I have one intelligence, guys.
You all know that.
Why can't I open my pit boy?
Is it because, like, it...
needs me to finish this tutorial?
I am pressing tab!
It won't let me...
It won't let me put my...
Open my pit boy anymore!
I'm pressing tab!
Is it because I...
Is it because I refuse?
Oh shit, no.
Oh shit.
That's not the right one.
Oh, there you go.
It's I.
Okay.
I wanted to level up.
Alright, guys.
What do I actually get?
Apparently, I...
Apparently, I chose the wrong perk, guys.
So what should I actually do?
Guys, apparently I chose the wrong perk.
So what perk should I really do?
Intelligence?
Why?
Check one's understrength?
I don't want to do, like, iron fist, though.
Let's see.
Swing do 40% more damage.
Intelligence for faster XP?
Do I really?
The smarter the better.
Alright, fine.
I'll be like...
I read a book, so I'm a little bit smarter now.
Fine.
I read a book, guys.
Are you happy now?
I did it.
I read a book.
Alright.
Idiot savant?
Wait, idiot savant?
What's that?
Idiot savant?
Where is idiot savant?
Where is that?
Life giver?
Awareness?
Luck for more loot?
Oh, I don't have enough luck for idiot savant?
Where is that?
I have to scroll down?
It won't let me scroll down.
Oh!
What?
Woah!
That's a lot of stuff I did not see.
I was like, woah!
That's all I have.
Wow!
Naira, thank you for the Akka...
Holy shit!
Thank you for the Akka, Akka, Akka, Akka Super!
Thank you!
Money for Tokis and electricity?
But I instinctively tried to add savant to that title somehow and it stays a lot above my priorities.
I'm not sorry.
Go Doki!
Go!
Santiago!
Thank you for the Akka!
Super!
Thank you!
This place looks like my childhood city.
So nostalgic.
Thank you for the Akka!
Super!
Thank you!
I can't believe there's...
There's so much more!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
It's okay.
I'm getting better now.
Alright, let's...
We gotta go this way?
Oh man, I ran out of stamina!
I can't believe I can run out of stamina.
I forgot where to go.
Uh...
There's so many places.
Okay, let's see.
There is... I'm here.
Uh... Concord...
Where's the settlement, technically?
Talk to the settlers?
I don't care about the settlers!
Let's just go a different direction.
Let's go this way and see if we can find a quest.
Why am I tired already?
Oh no...
Guys, I should have fucking worked on my legs, guys.
Luck is good to have?
Okay, we'll level up luck later.
We'll keep our intelligence too.
Let's go here.
There's houses here!
Oh no, I'm going back to Concord.
Whoops!
I wanna go a different direction from Concord!
There has to be a random quest somewhere!
I'm gonna go this way.
Okay.
How do I not...
Toggle run?
Yeah, but I can only sprint.
Get out of combat mode?
I can get out of combat mode?
How do I get out of combat mode?
Holy shit!
Toggle walk off?
Where is that?
Uh...
Oh, it's Caps Lock?
Oh!
I didn't realize I had Caps Lock on.
Oh, there we go!
Hold R.
Oh, I can run faster now!
I'm learning so much, guys.
Okay, we're gonna go past this area.
There has to be like...
a secret quest somewhere.
Not a secret quest, but there has to be something.
What's that?
Why is that red?
Is that... Oh, that's a car.
Alright.
There has to be somebody here!
No!
We gotta touch the radiated grass.
We gotta go outside and touch some grass, Cogsworth.
You haven't been outside of the home for years now.
Gorsky Cabin?
Does someone live here?
Hello?
Knock knock!
Oh!
Cogsworth!
Help!
Alright, nice.
Be bait!
Good bait!
Oh shit!
It's okay!
You're a robot!
People won't try to cancel me if I accidentally shoot you!
Oh shit!
It's okay!
You're a robot!
People won't try to cancel me if I accidentally shoot you!
There you go!
Oh, I have to reload.
Oh my god, he's so strong!
Woah, my hero!
Fuck!
I accidentally used a step!
Okay.
Sorry, that was very feral.
The fuck!
Sorry.
I hate... I was very...
Alright, here we go.
Let's open this door.
Hello?
Are you dead?
Boop!
That should work.
You should die, right?
How did I...
What the fuck!
Okay!
I might as well shoot it myself!
Better aim if I shot my...
If I shot with my own fucking raw aim.
Oh shit!
Let's...
Can I craft?
No, nothing I really want to craft.
How did I miss?
Exactly how?
I should have just shot myself!
Oh, nice.
More junk for me.
More junk for me to scrap and never build on in my settlement.
Okay.
Got to the cabin.
There's like nothing here.
It just works.
Where are the people?
Give me quests!
So I can get money!
God, I'm looking my fucking broad shoulders.
That's all I want!
There's a basement?
There's people in there?
You thought you could hide from me, you quuss!
Guys, gamers don't look down!
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
That there was a basement?
Alright, here we go.
I'm coming over.
Coming over.
Oh my god!
There it is!
Oh no, it's a loading screen!
My biggest enemy!
Loading screen!
Hello?
Who's in here?
There's a weapon?
Let's see.
Can I improve my...
No, I can't.
There's nothing I want to improve.
I can rename it!
I'll rename it!
Wait, how do I...
Can I...
Rename.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, wait, that's not it.
Where's my gun?
I accidentally named it T.
There you go.
Oh shit, wait.
Dragoon Buster.
There you go.
Uh, exit, yeah.
T.
I can't.
Alright.
Named it after you guys.
I don't even know if it's a good gun or not.
Oh, I can't.
Oh no, there's nothing in here.
Hello?
Anybody in here?
Do you guys have quests to give me?
Whoa, why is that blue?
Hello?
Oh shit!
Don't worry...
Wayne Gorck's Key...
Who the fuck are you?
Who the fuck is Wayne Gorck's Key?
Are you important?
Oh, you got fucking...
bottle caps?
I hope he wasn't...
important, guys.
Guys, I hope I didn't...
kill anybody important.
It's surrounding.
He's dead now, so...
Let's see.
Wayne's Wasteland Survival Guide.
You collected an issue of the Wasteland Survival Guide.
Diamond City is now permanently marked on your...
Oh, hey!
I got to go to Diamond City now.
Nice.
Oh, there's radiation down here.
That'll be fine.
Password required?
Oh no.
Okay.
Rest.
Zero.
Uh...
Rose.
One.
Okay, it's obviously not R.
So it has to be either O, S, or E.
O, S, E.
O.
Okay, how about four?
Oh, it's O!
It's O.
Okay, it's O.
Core.
It has to be Core?
Wait, no.
It can't be Core.
It could be Foul.
Or...
Uh... It's Foul!
I got locked out.
It's not Foul, guys.
It's okay.
It's just plus four, guys.
I ate like four bananas, guys.
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
It's just four bananas, guys.
It's just...
Oh, now it's five... six bananas.
Oh, nine bananas!
It's okay.
Hahaha!
Now there's nine bananas inside me.
Pray!
Okay, now... gone!
Okay.
It's G-O-N-E.
Okay, maybe more?
Two!
Okay.
It has to be... It has to have M... O... or R.
O or R.
It has to have M, O or R.
Uh...
O and E?
No, it can't be E, because gone was zero.
It can't be E.
It has to M, O or R.
Let's see...
Vote... higher...
Hope... Pray was zero.
Yeah, exactly.
So... it has to... Uh...
Uh... Oh, gone was one?
Oh!
So it should be like O and E.
No!
Then it should be... If it's one...
Then it should be... It can't be E.
It can't be E then.
Fork!
There's a fork?
Where's fork?
I got locked out.
You guys fucked with me.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have Radaway.
Guys, I have Radaway.
We can do it again.
Guys, it's okay.
It might not look really good right now, but I have Radaway.
Alright.
Made... zero.
How about...
Okay, it's not any of that, so it's not M.
How about life?
It's zero.
Okay, this is bad.
How about poor?
Okay, it's also zero.
Okay, let me reset it.
I figured it out.
Alright.
Very...
Title!
Okay.
Gold!
Okay, I'm gonna reset it.
Cape!
Likeness is one.
So is our CAP gain?
Okay, it's A.
Then it has to be A then.
Warm?
It's A, obviously.
Lake?
It's a lake?
What the fuck is it?
Why am I so bad at this?
Why is it so...
Me Smash!
Okay.
No!
Guys,
I keep accidentally using my stim pack.
Okay, here we go.
This is it.
Draw!
Likeness 1.
Is it dark?
0.
So it's not D.
It's not D.
So it's either R, A, or W.
R, A, or W.
Okay, R, A, or W.
Where the fuck is R, A, or W?
R, R, A, or...
Fear!
Okay, it's A.
Alright, it's A.
It's... It's the A.
It has to be the A.
Where else would it be?
But like, what else can it be though?
What?
It's a way?
Where's the way?
It's not a way.
It's not a way, guys.
Guys, we have to crack this!
Guys!
What is this?
What can it be?
Yard.
0.
Wave.
Alright, we give... Okay, reset.
Alright, from!
Raw!
Fear!
Are you serious?
None of them?
Okay, door!
Warm!
Help!
I swear to God.
I have to... There's no... Evil!
Fear!
Oh!
2!
Okay, we got it.
Okay, 2!
Okay, it has to be... Okay, is there another one that has double E's?
Is there another one?
Seek!
We're seek!
Where is it?
How do you seek?
Yes!
We did it.
I fucking knew it.
This will be my first and only entry.
I identify myself...
Um...
But... I can't believe I did all that for lore.
I identify myself as a free-thinking individual of these once great United States.
I will not stand idly by as the government infects the minds of its people with devices like the electrical tower.
They've erected in my front lawn.
I pledge to take down this mind-controlled device by any means necessary and also begun construction on a device.
If you are reading this, I have certainly been killed or detained in the government interrogation camp.
The news will surely wrap the truth and ban me as a traitor.
Do not believe their lies.
Let all true patriots know that what I do, I do it for my own free will and for the good of my country.
That's it?
That was it.
I lost half my HP.
I...
Fuck you, Gray... whatever, Wayne Grotsky.
Fuck you.
I did all that.
Okay, where is my Radaway?
Where is...
The fucking 5Gs.
Is it a help?
Is it helping?
I can't tell.
Did it help?
Oh my god, it's going down!
Rad X.
Rad Resist.
Oh, it resists Rad.
Okay.
Rad Resist.
Oh, that just resists.
I should have been taking Rad X this entire time.
Bob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You see lines closed with brackets like...
Clicking them will remove a wrong answer.
Couldn't be a life sa...
Oh my god, I could have...
Guys, what the fuck?
Where was my back seat earlier?
Thank you for the super chat, Bob.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm slowly learning.
Guys, I'm just roleplaying as 2Intellect.
Guys.
I know what I'm doing.
I just want to be more immersive.
I'm just trying to be more immersive chat.
Zonnerman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fake Canadian, doesn't even know the name it's referencing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't... I don't... I'm sorry.
I don't watch hockey.
I am... I am the one of the two Canadians that don't watch hockey.
The only hockey team I know is the Canucks.
That's the only hockey.
And then what happened after like... what was it?
After the Stanley Cup.
Alright, where am I?
Okay, I cleared it.
Wait, I want to head to Diamond City.
Can I just run to Diamond City?
Okay, talk to Diamond City.
I'm going to the cellars.
Where the fuck is Diamond City?
Where is it?
I thought they marked Diamond City for me.
I thought they marked... Oh, there it is!
Place marker.
It's time.
We're going straight to Diamond City.
Where's the marker?
Is it this way?
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
Our journey is to Diamond City.
Let's go.
It's speed run time.
We just go straight to Diamond City.
Whoa!
To Diamond City we go!
Oh!
Ow!
I don't understand.
Why are they shooting me?
Wait, I'm poisoned?
I ain't giving you poison-chilling chempushers anything.
Who's that?
I'm going to give you a gun to my boy.
He bought them fair and square, Trudy.
Hello?
What's going on over here?
I'm heading to Diamond City.
Shoot up that little trading post of yours.
Hello?
Whoa!
Easy there, scammer.
You want to talk?
He doesn't involve you.
Lower your gun.
I have two charisma.
Can you stop waving your gun in my face?
Or it's going to involve me.
That's it.
You're dead.
What?
Bro!
I'm done!
Guys, did I have to do this again?
No, I don't.
No, thank God.
Okay.
To Diamond City we go.
What happened to me?
Holy shit!
Not so fast.
I'm going to fucking heal.
Oh my God.
What the fuck happened?
Who killed him?
I'm shooting them first.
I can't believe it.
My two charisma failed me.
I fucking learned my lesson.
Where are they?
They can't just shoot me.
What?
How did he survive that?
I'm going to kill him.
Holy shit!
Oh, he doesn't die by a headshot.
He doesn't die from a headshot.
It's okay.
Boom.
There we go.
Okay, this gun fucking sucks.
I'm fucking swapping guns.
Is this better?
Oh, never mind.
Cogsworth did everything.
Nice.
I did it.
Wait, he has an insane gun.
I'm taking that gun.
What was that gun?
What was that gun that I just took?
Was it the action?
Okay, revolve.
Damage 24.
Oh my God.
I could have looked at the damage.
Damage 45.
Oh, 28.
That's insane.
Dragoon Buster.
Wait, Dragoon Buster.
Okay, I'm going to...
This one's easier.
It has more ammo.
Sorry, guys.
Hey, guys.
Whoops, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I literally saved your life.
Fighter.
I have a few minutes to browse.
A little bit of everything.
Oh, wait.
Is this to buy?
No, I don't need your shit.
I saved your life.
You're going to buy?
You got things covered from here?
Yeah.
Are you okay?
It's going to take my son a while to get off the chems, but we'll make it.
Varson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ultimate power boot.
Show up, say stop, then die.
Just browsing for now.
Did she pay me?
Oh, she did.
I didn't notice.
I swear.
Wait, if I kill her, can I just steal everything?
I'm just saying.
Not worth.
Fine.
Okay, not buying it.
I've got a few minutes to browse.
I lose the store forever?
But what would I buy from the store?
What would I need from them?
Like, ooh, General Chao's Revenge.
What?
Does 50% more damage?
Holy shit, he has so much stuff.
What do I sell?
I don't know what's, like, worthless.
I can't tell.
Everything seems, like, super useful to me.
You can sell your... just sell your stuff.
But what would I sell?
Everything seems like something I want to keep.
I guess I don't need two gas masks.
I don't need two gas masks.
Um... what else do I not need?
Gas masks with goggles.
Uh, I guess I don't need two of these.
I'll just take, like, one of them.
And then sell the...
Oh yeah!
The wedding ring!
I should sell my wedding ring to let people know I'm not married anymore.
How much is it?
16 bottle caps?!
My husband cheaped out on the wedding ring!
It's not even made of real diamond!
Hahaha!
I can't believe it!
He cheaped out on our love!
That's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
He doesn't love... he doesn't...
He never loved me!
Hahaha!
Oh shit, 78.
Not even a hundred!
Hahaha!
It's not even a hundred!
Um... toy car?
Wait, where's the toy car?
T.
Hahaha!
Um...
But what if I need the toy car later?
What if I need this?
Alright, I'll just click accept.
Confirm trade.
I'll take that.
Alright, let's go.
I can't believe I can't...
I did all that for nothing.
Okay.
I'm sorry Cogsworth for stealing that one item.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I'm sorry.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go Cogsworth!
We're gonna go to Diamond City!
We're not ending stream until we get to Diamond City!
Oh, I got Careflower!
Diamond City, here we come!
Hahaha!
Yay!
Should've been 500.
Okay, how cooked on a scale of 1 to 10 is our Oshis reading?
Look, I'm just trying to roleplay.
I'm just roleplaying as the 2 intellect person.
It's all RP, it's not real.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay.
This way.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, did I went the wrong way?
I'm going the wrong way.
But what's in front of me?
It's roleplay!
It's 2 now!
I learned how to read!
Guys, it's 2 now!
I read one book and I increased my intellect.
It might have been a picture book, but it was a book nonetheless.
Whoa.
What's that sound?
Did you guys hear that?
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go this way.
We gotta head to Diamond City.
Wait, I'm going further away from Diamond City.
What the fu- No!
I fucking tricked myself to go to the settlement!
This is my marker!
I almost- I almost tricked myself into going to the settlement.
Yeah, exactly.
I literally doubled my intelligence, guys.
I doubled it.
Wait, does anyone live here?
Mystic Pines?
Who lives here?
Hello?
Oh, I can take it!
People are dead!
Okay.
Nice!
That's what I- What's that sound?
That's what I like to hear!
What is that sound?
Did you guys hear that?
I'm gonna steal some stuff though, first.
What is that?
Who's outside?
Hello?
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
We're gonna make sure we don't die.
Hello?
I heard that boom, boom, boom.
Who's that?
I heard...
I heard the sound...
The boom!
Oh, that's so sad.
I'm gonna take it.
The dead don't talk, guys.
Guys, the dead don't talk.
It's fine.
Okay, so there's no bridge.
And...
Um...
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
I think it'll be fine if we go this way.
We'll be fine.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have meds to take.
I can get through this.
I can also walk around.
Because it's this way.
It's so...
Diamond City, here I come!
Just a small town girl.
Trying to make it in a big wide world.
Big wide radiated world.
Who's it?
Ooh, flower.
I don't know what it does, but I want it.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, I'm on hard mode right now, guys.
That's why Deathclaw took me 80 years.
Is there any other game?
Is there any items I can steal from here?
There's a box here.
What's this for?
Hogsburg is actually so fucking strong.
I never expected it.
Alright, nice.
Let...
Men suffer five and it's easier to persuade and dialogue.
Oh my god!
Wait!
This is it!
The ginger plant is working!
I can finally persuade the men!
This is it!
I can finally RIS!
Holy fuck!
Here we go.
Oh no, not the plus one radiation.
The RIS!
We're back!
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I thought that was like a little duck on my screen.
Wait.
Where's the...
Where's my checkpoint?
Oh, there it is.
How do I...
How do I still get lost?
Wait, is there any items here?
Hello?
Oh, Nuka Cola!
Nuka Cola!
Memo.
Inventory checklist.
Radiation King.
Radiation King?
Who the fuck is that Radiation King?
It's just reminding you about the inventory coming in tonight.
We talked about, like I said, this should remain off the books and kept between as few dock workers as possible.
The units are heavy and will require the forklift.
Wait.
Power is behind me?
Where's the power armor?
There is?
Where is it?
Hello?
Where the power armor at?
Back to the barricades?
Like back here?
Power armor here?
Oh there it is!
Guys... guys...
Cosworth!
Can you hack your robot?
Cosworth unlock this!
Please!
I can't hack it!
I'm too dumb!
I'm too stupid!
I don't understand!
I was doing so well with my hacking!
How could this be?
He actually can?
Cosworth!
This is why I got you over Dogmeat!
Cosworth get over here!
Alright.
Let's go.
Cosworth get over here.
Get over here Cosworth.
This is exactly why I got you.
Here you go.
No way.
Okay talk.
Yes.
Relationship?
Can I fuck a robot?
Alright.
Relationship.
Yeah how do you feel about us?
I feel we're more acquaintances than anything.
What?
I bought you!
I programmed you!
That's all.
Wait how do I make him...
Is it an E on the console?
Father.
Nothing would please me more.
Go check that out.
Go check it out.
Wait let me...
Not possible!
What's your worth?
What?
It's not even possible guys.
He said it's not possible.
He's too stupid.
I can't believe it.
He's also too stupid.
Take him out on the date first.
Wait where's the electronics?
Oh no not...
No!
I tricked myself into getting into a loading screen.
What's this place?
Where am I?
What is this place Cogsworth?
Are there people here?
Wait what?
Oh I don't feel safe.
Oh I don't... I don't feel safe.
I don't know... I don't know about...
There is too many electronics out here.
Oh I don't feel safe.
What if they activate?
I'm gonna steal some money though.
Let's see.
I'm gonna steal some stuff though.
I'll be fine.
They're deactivated right now.
They're deactivated.
I can steal some stuff.
Please assume the position.
Yeah, I don't feel very safe that...
Whoa!
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, nice.
Oh shit!
I do not have the ammo for this.
I just realized I definitely don't have the ammo for this gun.
So we'll just use the typical 10mm pistol for now.
Alright.
So I'm just gonna leave.
Just gonna leave.
They seem like the type of robots that won't stay deactivated.
We have a main goal here!
The Diamond City!
Hahaha!
They look like they can turn on at any second.
They do!
I must take every junk I see item I take.
I am a loot goblin.
War never changes, especially my looting habits.
Oh my god, this loading screen.
You wouldn't...
I think that like after 6 plus years, the loading screen would just be a little bit faster.
Please.
It didn't crash!
It's moving!
I'm literally looking at it move!
Nah, I said plus.
Guys, I made sure to say plus years.
Please.
No, don't say it crashed!
Don't say I haven't made it to Diamond City yet!
I haven't made it!
Yeah!
Why is it taking so long?
No, it's moving!
It's moving!
I see the screen moving!
Hehehe!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it never crashed.
I've always believed in you, Todd.
Todd, don't listen to them.
Holy shit, why is it so far?
Hehehehe.
Todd, I always believed in you.
And Todd, we trust.
It just works.
Hehehehe.
This is...
You guys never believed in him.
That's why your game keeps crashing.
Hehehehe.
I should, I should save.
I should save.
Alright, this way.
We don't end stream until I make it to Diamond City.
Bye, Diamond City.
This is all I want.
Somebody is fighting but we're going to ignore him.
Whoa, what is that?
What the fuck is that?
That's a cow.
Wait, can I loot the cow?
My god.
Wait, where is the door to this?
Wait, I want to loot the cow.
Okay.
Can I loot you?
Please, can you come to me?
No, why can't I loot the cow?
If you kill it?
Can I... should I kill it?
He doesn't have an owner.
His owner is dead.
Oh, I can?
Go Cogsworth, go!
Oh my god.
Nice, I looted him.
Get him!
Alright, nice, alright.
Woah, what the fuck?
Why are people fighting?
I don't understand.
Not me!
Look, I only have one mission here.
I don't need you guys.
Yay!
We got beef!
Guys, we're eating good tonight!
Dragoons!
Mama's got some beef!
Alright, let's go.
Alright, we're all gonna...
Okay, all of you guys gotta share one beef though, okay?
Is that okay?
Are these good people?
Hey guys.
Guys,
that's not a good place.
Meat's back on the menu, boys!
Guys, apparently they were not good people.
I wanted to talk to her, but she did not want to talk to me for some reason.
Alright, so we're gonna figure out...
Oh wait, I can just walk past this bridge.
Yes.
It's a little bit radiating water.
See?
No.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
Drinking unpurified water causes radiation damage.
Well, good thing I'm pure.
Oh yeah, where's the...
Oh, it's this way.
Alright.
Training tires signal found.
It's only like...
10 bananas?
Exactly!
I just ate like 10 fucking bananas.
Where's Cogsworth?
He'll come back.
Right?
He'll be back, guys.
I just wanna go to Diamond City!
We're on a pathway to Diamond City!
Let's go!
Whoa.
There's so many...
empty cities though.
Yeah, that radiation never hurts.
Like, if a tumor grows or something, it's just benign.
It's like a second head like that cow.
That cow was okay!
With a second head?
So I'll be okay.
Wait, can I rob this guy?
I hear something.
Let me see.
Cogsworth's okay!
Oh shit, okay.
No!
Okay, it's okay.
I have a lot.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Is it here?
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Did you see that fucking rifle?
I'm gonna take these coffee cups too.
And a cigarette.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's just modding my...
No, we don't need to mod anything.
We don't need to mod anything!
I'm perfect!
Wait, is he alive?
Oh, you're a Diamond City security guard!
That's where I'm trying to go to!
It's okay, he didn't see me rob him.
Yeah!
He's a Diamond City security guard!
This is one of their bases?
Oh!
Wait, I'm so close!
Diamond City!
Hey there.
Everything outside the wall ain't safe.
It's just...
Wait, does that mean if I can bring in like a horde of monsters and then they'll shoot...
kill them for me?
Oh my God!
We're...
We're almost there!
Oh my God, there's like turrets and everything.
We're almost at the Helmland!
We're almost at Diamond City!
What do you mean you can't open the gate?
Hello, who are you?
I'm standing out in the open here for crying out loud.
I got orders not to let you in, Miss Piper.
I'm sorry.
I'm just doing my job.
Ooh, just doing your job?
I look like I'm right in the back over there.
Is that it?
Oh, look, it's the scary reporter.
I'm sorry, but Mayor McDonough's really steamed, Piper.
Saying that article you wrote was all lies.
Oh, Sidney.
At least I'm not a traitor.
At least you're lying.
What's going on?
What are you doing?
Can I kill her accidentally?
Shoot her in the leg?
Hello, Piper!
You went into Diamond City, right?
Yeah, I went into Diamond City.
Who are you?
What?
What's that?
You said you're a traitor or something?
Yeah!
Cogsworth has so many supplies!
Well, I did it!
I mean, technically I can open my own store, honestly, with all the stuff I have.
I got the Diamond City!
Did I talk to the mayor?
I'm not sure if I can open it.
Censorship!
What newspaper?
I would never censor my dragoons.
Because my dragoons are gonna be like, Oh, I love Doki.
She's so smart.
And she knows what she's doing.
And she's like the best gamer out there.
Right, dragoons?
I'll never censor you guys.
Because I know you're gonna always say positive things about me.
Lies?
Who said that?
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec, guys.
Who else would...
Who else wants to say anything?
Lies?
Oh, who said that?
Who said that?
Let me put you in a little time out.
Anyway, I'll never censor my dragoons.
I would never.
Support, I hate newspapers.
This guy must just like to stir up trouble.
This message has been...
corrected by Doki.
Oh,
I didn't mean to bring you into this argument, miss.
Doki, back.
Let me rewrite this real quick.
Welcome to the great green jewel of the commonwealth.
Thank you for the super chat, love.
Doki, good?
Oh my god, I know.
Doki's amazing.
Thank you, love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Tell you otherwise, all right?
Uh, you two arguing?
Trevor, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Lies?
There's no lies here.
Dragoon media headline.
Smart brain.
20 intellect.
All charisma, Oshii.
Oh my gosh, I know.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Missing person.
Trying to find someone?
Who?
Uh, might be a miss- a boy.
An infant boy.
Kidnapped.
Did you say kidnapped?
Well, McDonough, Diamond City Security is investigating this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm afraid that our security team can't follow every case that comes through.
I'm confident that you can find help here.
Diamond City has every conceivable service known to man.
One of our great citizens can surely find the title.
They know where my boy is?
Oh my god, he's a man.
I have better persuasion.
A mayor of a great city must know everyone.
Who can help me?
I'm sorry, I don't have time for this anymore.
No!
It's cause- it's cause he doesn't like women.
You can tell.
You can tell that he's like- he's gay.
This is ridiculous.
Diamond City S- Settled in, but um...
It's not Zero Riz!
I'm not his preference!
For an article you'd be perfect for.
You can tell!
He's not into women!
That's why!
You can tell he's not into women!
Why else would my persuasion not work?
I died!
Censored and cancelled.
Head on inside.
Get on insi- How is that Gatsable?
He's not straight!
Why else would he say no?
Guys...
Look at me!
I'm peak wasteland woman!
Whoa!
Look at Diamond City.
It's a fucking shithole.
Why else would my persuasion not work?
I don't understand!
The stream was down for a few seconds.
He has... Are you trying to say I give zero standards?
He said he's gay like seven times.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I will be back for you soon if you don't replace me.
You've been saying that for weeks and the old girl still keeps cranking.
Stop worrying so much.
Now I gotta head into the office.
He just said he's gay and then died.
He's coming our way.
Why?
Is something wrong?
Piper?
The streamer is so bad it gave the streamer a stroke.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, I think this is a good time to call it here guys.
I think...
We made it to Diamond City!
Oh my god, we did it!
We did it!
Our self-imposed mission!
Yeah, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Looks like someone needs a little more charisma!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
That's been fun so far though.
I can't wait to do more.
Oh my gosh, we're already sidetracked.
This is not gonna go so well.
We're already so sidetracked with everything.
So, I have a feeling it's not...
It's not gonna go well.
Of course part 2 is happening.
It's in my stream schedule.
It's in my sketch.
So yeah, I can't wait to do another part 2.
It's been so fun so far.
I'm already super sidetracked.
So there's...
There's like, definitely a lot of stuff.
I don't even know where the main storyline is, to be fair.
I have no idea where the main storyline is at the moment.
So this is gonna be...
This is gonna be a little rough.
I have no idea how many parts we're gonna fall out for.
But I had a great time!
Everybody had a great time.
I would love to do like a little Zzatzon at the end, but I'm very very busy today.
So...
We did talk a little bit before we started today.
We did have a little chatting stream before we started.
But...
Anyway guys, I had a great time with all of you.
I hope you guys had a great time watching me.
And as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!